foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the premier online speed chess
tournament oh can you keep up
some time and what is going on for the
last seven years and counting the best
Blitz and bullet players in the world
have flocked to chess.com to prove their
worth at this format there is a
resignation of Wesley so breathe for the
first time since the five plus one in
seven years dozens have tried but only
two have ever worn this Crown Magnus
makes it look easy he wins the speed
test Championship spits in a row who
will be this year's Blitz King
he walks right into it
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
2023-speed Chess Championship is brought
to you by coinbase and we have a lot to
go still even though we sit in the
semi-finals alongside Dania daradinsky
I'm Danny wrench and Dania are you
pumped for Magnus Carlson versus Wesley
self no Danny I'd really honestly rather
be anywhere but here Magnus again so
could chess.com have come up with a real
way to entertain people this afternoon
you know what I I should have known if I
preempted you with such a slam dunk you
would totally you would totally take it
but we know we know how excited you
actually are you're like a kid in the
candy store like all of us and let's
remind everybody that this match is
gonna start in just a few minutes Magnus
Carlson is taking on Wesley so in this
semi-final matchup Diamond this is going
to be a battle of heavyweights and I
cannot wait to get into it we sit with
four players left in this year's SCC fun
fact on you those four players are the
only four players who have ever reached
the finals of the speed Chess
Championship your thoughts that fact
honestly speaks for itself it just
demonstrates the the hegemony that these
four players have demonstrated the way
that they've lorded over online chess
for the better part of a decade now
Danny pretty incredible stat
so so much to their careers a lot of
people maybe forget that to get to the
finals Maxine Bashi the grav eliminated
Magnus Carlson himself in 2020. uh
there's a there's a lot to these four
players but we've talked about the four
players who the who are the only ones
who ever make the finals let's take a
look at the two players who have won the
SEC the only two players to ever have
one of me who might it be there
that's a young looking Magnus Carlson
I mean 2016 that was a completely
different time you know with different
people different Magnus younger Magnus
and then hikaradakamura absolute
domination five years in a row he
defeated mvl he defeated Wesley Son and
one of the most exciting SEC finals
probably the most exciting in 2022 a
one-point victory over Magnus Carlson
Hikaru Danny is the big boss Magnus is
the other big boss that's the way it's
going to be that's the way it has in it
no sorry go ahead I was gonna say and if
we take it from the angle of magnus's
Legacy because we're talking about him
here today before he throws down against
Wesley so I don't think Magnus is too
happy about that right it was a
thrilling match against Hikaru Nakamura
but he doesn't want this Nakamura facial
expression trained to continue he'd like
to put an older Magnus maybe even a
Magnus with a beard and some long hair
at the end of 2023 as we look at this
card here
listen uh Magnus has had a chip on his
shoulder Danny no question about it
he's got a chip on his shoulder he wants
to get it done and despite the fact that
that he's had maybe uh some thoughts
about his own play as not being the
greatest he is getting the job done uh
and he's winning by some of the largest
margins of Victory he's ever had against
players like young the Palm Nashi were
you surprised to see the dominance in
the final score or maybe even that nepo
didn't even reach double digits for the
first time in his SEC career I mean I
wasn't surprised that Magnus won this
match I think he was the heavy favorite
I think Jan really really struggles
against Magnus it's not like he lost any
world championship matches against him
but it's terrifying Danny it's
terrifying that magnus's average
accuracy was over 90 percent he played
very good solid clean chess and then you
look at Magnus in the interview and he's
like yeah I'm expecting more from myself
well what more do you expect from
yourself and if Magnus believes that he
can do even better then what actually
happens if Magnus plays to the peak of
his abilities does he score 26 points in
an SEC match it's terrifying to face him
right now yeah
yeah well and I think uh Magnus laughed
at himself and everyone remembers one of
the most viral moments of the match when
he plundered his Queen taking a six and
so he he he's playing some of the best
chess he's ever played in the SEC
despite a few arguably throwaway games
moments where he blundered went full
botes Gambit which he never really want
to do in the SEC against 15 of the best
players in the world if you are the 16th
and hoping to win it all so all right
let's also talk a little bit
about uh what Magnus said in the
interview after he beat nepo Dandy he he
made comments about what he thinks about
facing Wesley so how he feels about his
chess and I'll let you respond to this
quote where he said if I'm in good shape
he's going to have to play at his very
best just to make it exciting and your
thoughts on on Magnus saying that I
think it's refreshingly honest and Danny
I I think some people in the chat might
look at this and say oh you know it's a
burn and he doesn't respect Wesley that
there isn't even an iota of of that that
I perceive in this quote Magnus is being
realistic he knows the kind of Chess
that he's been playing online in Blitz
in Rapid formats over the over the past
year over the last couple of years and
he knows that Wesley will have to step
it up and as they said about Alexander
alekine the third world champion you
know they have to beat me in the opening
in the middle game and in the end game
Wesley will have to perform at his a
plus plus game in all three time
controls to even stand a chance
it's funny we've talked about that a lot
to beat Magnus Carlson you have to play
the very best moves and you have to play
them fast okay yeah well uh will Wesley
get that job done let's talk about what
he did against all the Reza farusha
because he did play a lot of the best
moves and he did play them fast but it
was also a bit of a bit of a bumpy ride
some inconsistent scores if you look at
a flipped 7-2 result in the first two
portions before we had a nail biter and
a thriller and bullet in Armageddon how
did you feel about Wesley's play and
that he ultimately got the job done
against Borussia there my God Danny
bumpy ride uh you're like that airline
pilot you know everybody's screaming in
the concrete uh folks we hit a couple
mile bumps uh Over the Rockies here uh
we'll be okay this match was crazy
Wesley so jumping out to that five-point
lead Robert and I thought that this was
going to be a blowout nothing was
working for alireza and then bang
complete 180 Wesley goes down by two
points in the bullet Ali Reza's best
time control and finds it in himself
finds the inner strength to stabilize to
come back from that deficit and then to
score in the Armageddon which was one of
the most high pressure moments in SCC
history the way that Wesley handled that
was really kind of nothing short of
impressive I agree with you I was I was
under playing it it was turbulent and
I'll just call it what it is but I'm
also gonna gonna build on that storyline
because I I agree with you that I wonder
if winning in come back fashion and
bullet and then needing Armageddon to
get over one of the best bullet players
in the world let's remember farrugia
beat Magnus Carlson in the bullet Chess
Championship does that actually help
Wesley's confidence coming into this
matchup against Magnus right let's bring
up his his SCC semifinals results
historically we know that uh playing
Magnus Carlson is is one of the few
names he hasn't seen but your thoughts
on how confident Wesley so is heading
into this matchup versus Magnus Carlson
well we were talking before the show
Danny I'll attribute this to you
confidence is a huge component of Wesley
so success we have two different Wesley
shows we have the Wesley so uh of this
year's SCC of the chess.com Global
Championship when he feels that he's
capable of scoring he's incredible he
can go an entire match he can go an
entire tournament without losing a game
as he did in the cgc when he feels that
he's not quite in the best form and you
know he's making some blunders his place
slows down a lot and that's not the kind
of Wesley so that his fans want uh to
show up today against Magnus
all right well said and and we see a
confident Wesley so you mentioned the
cgc I've mentioned the Fisher random
World Chess Championship and Norway
where he beat Magnus we know that he can
get it done and as we saw there in his
in his SEC record he's only lost in the
semis to one person Hikaru Nakamura uh
and Wesley by the way has only ever lost
to two people historically in the speed
Chess Championship those are Magnus
Carlson and hikara Nakamura and so I
think if there's a confidence factor
that might have been missing this is the
best storyline Wesley could have asked
for he beat farrugia it took it took
focus it took Thrills it took nerves
being under control and will he be able
to maintain that now as we look
specifically at the head-to-head we've
hyped it enough now let's start
comparing these players side by side
Donya what what uh what speaks to you in
regards to their history in the SEC
before we get to their stats on the
board
well what speaks to me is again uh just
to continue that narrative about the two
different Wesley sews right I mean you
look at 2018 2019 runner up runner up
and he came very close in the finals of
both of those years I mean to keep it
within five points against
hikaranakamura is an accomplishment in
itself Magnus is the more consistent
online player and that's the scary
aspect of this for Wesley so Magnus
hasn't had the kinds of performances
last couple of years in the SEC we saw
the kind of chip on the shoulder that he
had during the World Cup Danny and I'm
sensing the exact same Vibes for Magnus
Carlson this year listen I'm tired of
not winning this tournament this
tournament is prestigious everybody
watches it I want to make my mark on
this event this year and Magnus Carlson
and he's on a mission like that is
pretty terrifying
it's terrifying of course everyone
already thinking about what would that
look like if Magnus sentencar had a
rematch but Wesley so would like to say
something about that before we just
consider consider another epic match of
these two heavyweights in Nakamura and
Carlson let's look at our Deloitte game
analytics remember that Deloitte is uh
industry leader in their world
partnering with chess.com to bring you
these insights and the game within the
game let's talk about the stats as we
compare Magnus Carlson and Wesley so I'm
just going to jump right to the punch
line because I think it relates to the
furusia victory Wesley had you have to
take a look
at that third fourth item down where
Magnus Carlson's record against Wesley
so and bullet is startling
we verify this is real I'm looking at
this I knew this that before the show
and I still can't believe it
yeah it's
it's wild it speaks to the things we've
talked about that when things go off the
tracks for Wesley they can really go off
the tracks because no one just loses 10
games like that at this level but it's
the reason I said if that ends up being
the storyline and Wesley so can build on
the confidence of beating farrugia and
bullet who beat Magnus Carlson in the
bullet Chess Championship do we see that
line item in bullet change big time and
Wesley so reversed his fortunes against
Magnus Carlson yeah I don't think that
Wesley is necessarily thinking about
this stat you know 22 oh I'm never going
to win a bullet game against Magnus you
know all players are moving on this is a
different era of Chess everyone's more
experienced everyone's better at the
time scrambles and so I think Wesley has
turned over a new page
um and he's defeated Magnus Carlson in
mini matches during the covet era
remember those online tournaments Wesley
won quite a few of them so it's not
unprecedented for him to defeat Magnus
in a match format and that gives him
confidence that I think outweighs his
individual visual head-to-head scores in
in the bullet
okay all right well let's dive into
Deloitte again there they are our
official game stats partner and let's
take a look at some more data that
compares these two players side by side
what speaks to you here is it is it
Magnus Carlson's win percentage he wins
more games than he loses withdraws
combined or anything else about
comparing these two guys head to head
well these are two of the most
experienced SCC players that we're gonna
get they don't feel the kind of same
butterflies in their stomach at the
start of the match that a lot of
different players feel that's I think
promises us a very very high level match
from the very first moves obviously
they're Peak ratings
are unbelievable Magnus Danny I think
one of only two players to cross 3300
Blitz on chess.com uh the other one of
course is Hikaru Nakamura I was gonna
say is the other one you I was 32.50 but
I mean that happened once it was a
Quincy Dink and 3300 is in the freaking
stratosphere
I was partly teasing because I think
whenever we say two players and online
records we often do think of Nakamura
Carlson but I actually when I said it I
wasn't kidding you have you have put up
your own your own uh runs there and so
uh anyway I just I love you I just
wanted to say that I love you I'm fine I
said it on camera okay let's move on to
our smarter chess predictions let's move
on to the smarter chess predictions
because we've seen what the stats tell
us now what does smarter chest tell us
it looks it looks like a prediction that
could build into a blowout for Magnus
and so which is the time control do you
think Wesley If he if he was gonna Shock
the World here and and send Magnus
Carlson home where do you think that
that process starts I'm going to speak a
different normally I say it's always the
five plus one it's always the start I
actually think Wesley's gonna be fine in
the five plus one I think the three plus
one is where Wesley really needs to keep
things stable because remember against
farusha he went 2-7 in three plus one he
gave faruga all of that five-point lead
back Magnus he said that he likes all
time controls equally I I mean this
match can go one of ten different
directions Danny it's impossible to
predict but I think Wesley has to make
sure that in the three plus one he stays
even with Magnus on the clock and that
he eliminates those one move blunders
you cannot give Magnus any easy points
yeah well I I appreciate that because if
I was to if I was to argue that if
there's one player who can do that it
might be Wesley so he is as I've shared
a lot in terms of the data that we do
and the fair play stuff and all the
things we look at Wesley has played some
of the highest quality in terms of pure
accuracy three minute chess we've ever
seen
um and I think he is statistically the
most accurate chess player in the 3-1
portion of anyone who's ever played the
format and so if somebody could hold
their own in Blitz there we know that
when Wesley is is clicking on all
cylinders he is a very tough out as
we've talked about right he's just so
technically accurate he's hard to beat
so if he keeps it close and that bullet
confidence carries over maybe he does
get it done but all right Dania what's
at stake we know that we've got a
hundred fifty thousand dollars in prizes
for the speech test Championship which
again is uh not a bad not a bad amount
of scratch to take home given given the
total Blitz commitment there the highest
priced film we've ever had but we know
these players want even more than that
they want to win the whole thing the
winner advances to the final today earns
7 500 guaranteed and the additional 7
500 is split based on win percentage how
come every time I I say split on Boom
percentage I have to bring up that I
wish more tournaments did that to keep
chess exciting and put money on the line
with every single game Dania your chance
to tell over-the-board organizers that
I'm right and that they should do more
of that over the board organizers Danny
is right and you should do more of that
but in all seriousness in all serious
I'm always there for you Danny of course
you don't don't doubt for even a second
I'll always take you aside but it really
is the case that you want to motivate
players when they're facing let's say a
blowout and I think the SEC format is
really good at that but it's also really
good at preventing that situation from
occurring in the first place because
even when you've got a four or five
point deficit the players always believe
that they have a chance at a comeback
and those are not just empty cliche
words Danny we see regular five six
points comebacks as as as recently as
the Perugia show match
yep well and you and I as as chess fans
and and kids who grew up playing the
game and and could talk about formats
forever and I think you know there's all
kinds of ways we we've tried to tackle
speaking as an organizer keeping chess
exciting no matter what the format is
even in a blowout even in round Robins
whatever and I and I do believe there's
something to putting something at stake
in every game Wesley so knows what's at
stake here today he would love to send
Magnus Carlson home and move on to a
finals match versus either Maxine
Bossier the group or Hikaru Nakamura
he's uh he's ready
he's in Berlin uh and he's focused on
you
yeah
I don't know who that is but Wesley is
in Berlin I think he just finished uh
actually a blitz round of Blitz chess
today at the Armageddon uh Series so
he's nice and warmed up of course a
little bit of a disadvantage when you're
playing away from home that means you're
playing on a laptop that means you're
not playing on your most comfortable
desk Magnus by the looks of it uh I
think he is home he's wearing that
hoodie he seems nice and comfortable so
Wesley he's got a very very difficult
three hours ahead of him Danny he needs
to bring his A-Plus game from the very
first moose because Magnus you know you
know how it is he just hits you before
you even know what's happening you're
like oh my God I'm down four points when
did this happen
agreed and I worry about that that that
thing you just pointed out that Wesley
clearly not at his at his most
comfortable home environment although
every time we've observed Wesley people
wonder how could he be comfortable he's
often like got his like computer on a
chair we can see in the fair play Cam
and you're shouting out that Wesley
Wesley has some unique ways that he
likes to play online chess with a small
board in a big and a big monitor we've
also observed so so maybe for Wesley it
doesn't matter whether he's at home or
comfortable uh but as you said Magnus
Magnus is at home we see him in that in
that natural environment and I think we
see the players
getting set to take off here in any
moment Donya so uh so I'm pumped I know
you are I'm incredibly pumped Annie this
is going to be a high level fun match
unmissable action and Magnus he's
wearing a hoodie I think that's an
underrated way to play online chess I
always play in a sweatshirt with a hood
it just makes me a little bit more
comfortable and then make it you know 63
degrees in my room I don't know what
Magnus is up to there
well here we go again everybody it is
again the speed Chess Championship it is
again presented by coinbase we've
already got about 5 000 plus of you on
YouTube 3000 on Twitch we know that's
going to build throughout the day
because guess what we have liftoff it's
Magnus versus Wesley and we have what do
we have here are we gonna get a Berlin
that's on the Berlin a Berlin from
Berlin no he's gonna play Asics
okay
well I'm excited I'm excited this is uh
this is going to be great here we have
D3 uh talk a little bit about why this
is kind of the popular flexible way to
avoid the most forcing lines these with
these days Donya it's been called a
sideline but I don't think it should be
referred to as a sideline anymore I mean
D3 is essentially as popular as the
mainline short castle and short Castle
allows the open re Lopez where black
takes on e4 it also allows a bunch of
very topical Lines within the mainline
D3 a little bit less theoretical a
little bit more flexible and Carlson
takes the ambitious approach getting his
Bishop out to G5 this often leads Danny
to very sharp positions especially if
black plays H6 and then a G5 to
eliminate that PIN
oh great and I want to just make an
observation early that you note the pace
and the deliberate nature with which
these guys are using their time Donya I
think you know what that means I think
these guys are already thinking about
preparation that they brought here and
they're taking this very seriously they
are not blitzing through this with some
Shenanigans sideline B3 style openings
right they are they are really trying to
get Theory here to maybe try to take the
other person
um by surprise I'm going to Hazard a
guess that we're gonna see more
variability in the opening from Carlson
than we will from Wesley I think Wesley
will probably rely on one E4 uh and then
Italians but Magnus I think from both
sides uh is going to vary his openings
and try to find the kinds of positions
that make Wesleyan come and we know how
good Magnus is at that how Universal he
is more so than all of the other top
players and they're already incredibly
Universal as we see an interesting
transformation here Danny Carlson pushes
D4 now he tries to ruin uh Black's Queen
Side Pawn structure but in return you do
give up the bishop pair potentially if
black takes to the pawn okay he took
with the bishop interesting
takes with the bishop which means we get
more trades the structure slightly
favors white uh but we're no longer in
the opening book stage you see that
evaluation bar on the left everybody
changed change from a percentage to a
pure evaluation white is a teeny bit
favored because of the structure but
Johnny give us some highlights what are
the plans here for both sides well I
like black structure uh as ugly as that
pawn structure looks I would compare it
to a bumper on a car it's functional
you've got the open B file so you could
stick a rook on V8 at some point and
tickle uh that B2 Pawn but black is
likely going to play against that E4
Pawn that pawn is a strength yes it
controls space in the center but it's
also a Target and black could put a rook
on E8 maybe a queen on E7 and at the
right moment black can push the button
and play G7 G5 unpinning the Knight and
so Magnus has to make sure that he keeps
that E4 Pawn protected we're likely
going to see him Castle kingside he
might also Castle Queen side kind of
like he did against Vincent kymer uh in
in that World's Cup game I think that's
exactly what he's about to decide right
now Danny that's a huge decision right
castle queenside and we are all in for a
crazy game where white advances in Black
attacks or Castle kingside keep it safe
Donya why is it not the best for white
to take here and double these pawns for
the viewers I'm asking for a friend I
obviously know the answer but please
help me
well I think he actually might take on
F6 if he feels uncomfortable black might
recapture with the queen there and again
it's so important to indicate that the
pawn structure Danny is the most
visually arresting element of the
position but it's also not necessarily
the most important after the trade
occurs black will be threatening to push
F6 F5 harassing the E4 pawn and white
will no longer be able to Castle
queenside because the F2 Pawn is going
to hang I think Magnus took not because
he likes this end game but because he
felt uncomfortable keeping the Queens on
the board we have a completely equal end
game I would put a rook on B8 and start
with that just accentuating the pressure
on the queen side but there's F5 but but
no Wesley likes your idea by the way we
should point out quickly uh just that if
tipped F5 Rook to E2 is going to be the
problem so Magnus kind of saw this
coming quickly puts the Rook on E1 let's
also observe time here Donya very equal
for both players right now on the clock
yeah I don't think the clock is going to
be a deciding factor until uh the next
segment both of these players are
particularly Magnus are excellent at
time management of course if you're
Wesley you want to make sure that you
don't overthink it f takes C4 okay
Magnus will probably recapture I would
guess with the Knight and threaten the
fork on F6 and Wesley will centralize
his Bishop uh by putting it on on D4
okay Knight takes E4 we'll get Bishop to
D4
we're going to see this right away
okay B3
protect your pawn and B3 is better than
C3 you're not looking to force it yeah
okay
you know white actually might be seizing
a slight Advantage here the B file
pressure has been exterminated that pawn
on B3 is super well protected and the
Knight on e4 can be used kind of as a
chisel you could drop back to G3 there
we go the F5 square is a weakness it's a
long-term weakness black and bring his
King up to G6 and it's not like you're
suffering right away but in the long run
White's three on two Pawn majority could
be used to generate more kingside
pressure I would go King F1 and maybe
even trade the other pair of Rooks with
rookie one
yeah it's interesting because normally
with pawns on both sides of the board
you think the bishop is a slightly
better piece than the Knight but in
cases like this the bishop lacks any
Targets on the queen side they're all in
light squares and the pawn weaknesses
kind of afford the Knight some
flexibility to kind of poke and prod
right Donya so that in fact he's doing
exactly that plan he's kind of saying
look maybe my winning chances aren't
great but I actually like my knight
versus your Bishop in this end game and
you and I often say that the Knight is
the peskier piece to deal with with low
time right even if effectively the
bishop is is doing fine so
so what kind of chances you're giving
Magnus to to squeeze this one out
potentially major chances especially if
the Rooks come off the board black will
no longer have any chances to create a
past Pawn on the queen side that's the
big problem it's not that the queen side
pawns are weak per se it's that it's
very very difficult to counteract white
spawn majority which is a healthy
majority by creating a pass Pawn on the
week on The Queen side I really like
Wesley's decision though to keep the
Rooks on the board and play for active
counter play he wants to push A4 open up
the a file and activate his Rook on the
second rank practically speaking I think
it's a better chance than trading Rooks
and suffering at infinitum
okay sorry I lost my focus there because
it was a funny comment in chat oh chat
you're distracting me again but okay
A4 for black makes sense and then we get
an open a file but here we see Rook G4
and the King has a big decision to make
right because if you back up you're
looking at tactics like this and if you
come toward the center you're actually
split from the pawn and and I don't know
if there's an immediate way to take
advantage of that but white has
weaknesses to poke at long term here
it's hard to coordinate your peace
tandem if you're white because A4 is
looming large uh so you know you want to
make sure that your pieces can defend
the C2 Pawn uh in the long run so King
E2 comes to mind but King E2 maybe walks
into a check on E8 he brings the Knight
back to E2 he actually sends the bishop
back or traps the bishop oh I think five
is the idea
so wait which line Bishop E5 is what I
would do here with what try to induce F4
and Danny F4 would have been a terrible
move because it would have sectioned off
The Rook which now laterally moves to A4
pressuring the A5 fun good move by
Magnus
yeah pressuring the A5 pump but also
stopping Black from getting any counter
play you never want your Rook defending
a little guy and that Rook is stuck
defending that weakness though I think
we should watch out for some ideas of
this bishop getting out of out of the
out of the comfort zone or lost in the
woods it's not clear yet but uh
but all right G3 has played Magnus just
playing flexibly on both sides of the
board also preparing maybe an entryway
for the king
yeah it's infuriating for Wesley he's
got weaknesses on both sides of the
board A5 of course but also H6 so The
Rook could trampoline from one side of
the board to the other via the fourth
rank you know on demand you could go
Rook H4 Rook A4 so black is essentially
at White's command and speaking of Rook
H4 I think he's trying to Garner the F4
Square for his Knight but he's saving
that check for a rainy day
yeah I like that patience not just for a
rainy day but also for time pressure you
never want to play forcing moves when
your opponent is clicking down on the
clock because then they have a forcing
response playing poke and prod chess I
think is one of the last skills people
really develop in chest on you being
very patient because look what happens
people make mistakes when you leave them
to their own devices rather than forcing
moves and I love this patient approach
from Magnus and they make mistakes
because they're sick and tired of
Defending passively but the moment you
try to make an active move you know the
medicine is worse than the disease Rook
H5 chiseling at some of these weak
squares in the center now Knight D3 is a
huge threat because you won't be able to
defend C5 I think Wesley's only chance
is to push A4 essentially close your
eyes and try to create Queen side
counter play at all costs but with 30
seconds on his clock I'm really worrying
about Wesley's practical chances here he
might be losing this first one but
there's a four
he plays A4
Magnus gonna think about the right way
to yeah Knight D3 was the other real
threat here because that C5 Pawn is
going nowhere C4 and if you play Rook A5
there's B4
I would play C4 and Rook A2 and Wesley
finds the only series of moves that
guarantee practical drawing chances 14
seconds though and he's got a long
defensive road ahead of him
what a nice idea
create a weakness go after the C2 Pawn
unfortunately still tough Knight B4 is a
fork on the A4 rook and the C6 Square
Magnus Pops in with check
um can't go back you get mated have to
go forward and give up D4 with check no
Rook takes D4 it's over just two extra
responses
that was a that was a sneaky problem
there that the Knight was forking a rook
and a square that led to threatening
Checkmate and this is um this is a very
Magnus s game look at that look at that
game Mark bar below Dania I call that
the Magnus measurement tool stick I just
made that up
because look at the game even no but
don't you seriously look at it's even
even and then what happens for magnus's
side
it's almost magical the way that he's
able to create these chances out of out
of nothing I mean he traded on F6 as he
wins the first game uh by taking F7
that'll be three extra pawns Wesley
resigns it's equal no problems for black
boom in the span of five moves suddenly
the position is unpleasant then suddenly
you're dead lost and you didn't even
make a perceptible mistake how how does
he do this how does this happen I know
that Magnus measurement tool stick
doesn't roll off the tongue like the a
monometer does which was the nickname I
gave the other day but that game Mark is
something we're going to see the Magnus
measurement where he just he takes you
into the woods to use the tal quote
right the deep dark woods and he just
gets you lost in there are you pouring
yourself coffee
um I have two beverages actually one is
coffee and one is a green beverage but I
will uh maintain the suspense by not
revealing what it is I hope it's not
absent I'm just gonna worry I take my
commentating Duty seriously the absent
this for after the commentary okay all
right well there aren't many green
drinks that you have besides ag-1 which
is a fantastic daily drink to help boost
your overall health and wellness ag1 one
of the official uh whatever sponsors of
hey I just rolled off the tongue
that transition
Wesley so gets a uh a knight on E5 and
his B3 systems uh you you you said is
this what you thought Wesley would do in
the first stage or is this the result of
losing the first game or you think he'll
poke and prod a little bit
he will probably poke and prod a little
bit but I'm not a big fan of this of
this opening setup I think this is right
up magnus's alley he's super solid here
as he trades off the dark Square Bishops
and it's completely equal position I
would even maybe prefer black because
the Knight on D2 has a hard time finding
a good home Danny because look at that
pawn on D5 as one of Robert Hess would
point out it restricts the Knight
prevents it from going to C4 from E4 so
we're gonna get a long kind of
positional cagey maneuvering battle in
this game
Robert loves highlighting that a pawn
dominates tonight how many times does he
mention it per commentary match a lot
well I think I mentioned it more often
than he does now because I'm always like
Robert Hess would point out that the
pawn restricts the night Robert has
coined hey let's point out the bishop is
the wrong color square of the corner
right
um
there you go I guess we can't spell
chess without Hess and we talk about him
even when he's not here by the way
Nakamura is playing Maxine Basha the
grav that is tomorrow you see below us
our other semi-final matchup but okay
we're here with E5 and F4 Wesley changes
the structure Donya which of course
comes with giving black the house right
a free ride over here on the queen side
but he's hoping for some big space what
are your thoughts here yeah nothing's
gonna happen too fast in this position
because if white pushes G4 and F5 too
fast then black will take on F5 and then
the E5 Pawn will become weak it's hard
for Magnus to generate chances on the
queen side though Danny I would point
out the pawns on A3 and B3 if black
plays B5 you've got a classic situation
that I think will be very relatable for
most players where if you push A4 white
pushes B4 if you push B4 white pushes A4
there is a name for these Pawns in
Russian
um but I don't know how to translate a
specific situation where if you push one
Pawn your opponent keeps things locks up
locked up by pushing the other and so we
see Magnus taking a slow burn approach
deploying his Queen and connecting his
Rooks let's watch how he tries to
generate chances on the queen side here
we might get a textbook lesson
I love that and it is a very common
defensive maneuver to put your pawns
side by side to lock it up just like
this but note that Magnus pushes it
first so that maybe now when C5 comes
it's maybe a little harder to keep it
locked up and in fact Magnus does it
justifying his Queen on C7 and and not
allowing white to have fully locked up
the queen side so so I get that answers
your question Daniel that's how he was
going to do it right there yes but now
he's got that weak Pawn on B7 and Wesley
can say wait a second two can play at
that game you're not the only you don't
have a monopoly on the queen side and
you've got a really bad Bishop on H7
that's biting on granite so whatever you
do
keep that pawn chain healthy yeah to
keep Black's Bishop out of the game I
would even trade Queens here and either
stick a knight on D4 or maybe play this
kg move Rook to A2 and then Knight D4 to
make sure that your Pawn is well
protected
okay he plays 1944 first wow Knight B8
you put the Knight back on its original
Square so that you can come to C6 and
get rid of the key centralized defensive
piece of C2 that's the reason the eval
bar switch by the way the computer the
computer suggested Knight B8 is the best
and by the way Magnus found it in just a
few seconds he found it instantly and
now after B takes C6 which I think we're
gonna see both Bishops are out of the
game White's Bishop is facing the same
plight uh as blacks it's also going to
be staring into a pawn chain black could
also put that Rook on C3 and much like
the last game remember magnus's Rook on
A4 it's the same type of thing where
Wesley is the one tied down to that weak
Pawn on A3 I think it's still equal but
I feel like Wesley's gonna get a little
bit uncomfortable here because he was
better going into that end game and he
missed This brilliant Knight beat at
Knight C6 maneuver but let me play
devil's advocate for to that because
Wesley has the only open file you can
put the Rook on A2 and this bishop you
pointed out is still deadlocked like
what exactly is stopping white from
improving the king I guess the problem
is when I get there where do I go next
if I go too far I can get myself in
trouble but I'll put us I'll ask it this
way what is Black's plan here Beyond
just the Improvement of Rook C3 no Danny
your point is very well taken I I'm
starting to change my mind about this
position and I think the reason Magnus
didn't put his Rook on C3 is precisely
because if the king reaches D4 The Rook
literally was going to be trapped and
it's it's hard to push D4 because you
open up White's Bishop so that seems to
carry much more drawbacks than strengths
now Wesley is going to centralize his
King he's going to try to seize further
control of the B file and it feels like
he's starting to Garner some practical
chances in this end game
yeah I agree and I was feeling that
because even though I looked at it
objectively and thought Wesley missed
him like white has more ways to improve
than black although this is a great move
from Magnus because as I said when
there's only one open file whoever owns
it often controls the highways and
Magnus is not going to let Wesley sit on
it so
she might want to Rook C3 also Danny and
then Rook ac5 but that seems really
risky you're gonna walk Rook you're
gonna walk both your Rooks into the C
file
wow
he's thinking about it you do that you
might be Magnus Carlson can we go to the
Batcave and analyze this real quick
let's do it
let's do it if you go Rook Rook five to
C3 and I go King D4 and you put this
Rook on C5
but white doesn't have the right type of
Phillips screwdriver to attack either of
the Rooks if you had a dark squared
bishop or even a knight the Rooks would
be so flimsy but somehow they're they
look terrible but they're but they're
strangely stable white has to go Rook
BB2 Danny and I'm not sure exactly how
you're getting those Rooks off of the C
file it's hard to believe but and Magnus
doesn't believe it he doesn't go for it
but I think he should have
hmm I think you're right because we have
it on the board and the computer says
it's about the same eval as it was
earlier and uh are artificially
intelligent Overlord frowns upon
magnus's move says this was not as good
he should have gone for this idea now
that I'm looking at it you were right
Donya wow and King D2 Wesley you know
that that ship has sailed and now Rook
from B1 is going to come up to B4 and I
mentioned earlier that white would be
tied down to the A3 Pawn now it's going
to be black who's tied down to the A4
pawn and Wesley has a serious Advantage
here
by the way there's there's weird ideas
where the Rook still gets trapped if
you're not careful with the bishop
grabbing this diagonal with D4 the move
order matters but I want to point it out
because if somehow black has to play D4
themselves this bishop will just pop
right back to that diagonal and be super
happy with the progress so so this is
this is looking more and more awkward
and by the way the time on the clock
reflects how Magnus feels he doesn't go
down on time for no good reason right
Magnus knows this is a bit of a struggle
to figure out the problem is that you're
ultimately going to have to break
through and that's going to be hard
because even if black defense passively
traits one pair of Rooks and then simply
keeps the other Rook on A5 how are you
going to add an attacker to the A4 Pawn
there is this long-term maneuver Bishop
F3 Bishop D1 Danny and then Pawn to C3
which is a cute little positional
concept but something's going to tell me
Magnus is not going to take this sitting
down and he's going to try to generate
active counter play Maybe by pushing C5
and kicking The Rook away from uh B4 I
definitely would not take with a pawn
here and give black a passer on the a
file
yeah that would that would seem
ill-advised Wesley double checks it
though he takes before with the rook and
I I think your plan by the way G4 stop
you're playing so maybe Magnus actually
likes it but it is still a long road for
for Wesley to have a Target the problem
I have
is what does Magnus do to stop it is he
gonna play C5 I guess he will that
that'll be the key and another reason he
might have pushed G4 I'm talking about
the distant future H5 and H4 followed by
a trade on G3 could create uh an
eventual Target on G3 and black stroke
on A5 can potentially swing back over to
the king side all of that doesn't take
as much time as it appears but right now
we're going down a different path C4 is
an excellent move by Wesley carving out
the long diagonal for his Bishop he is
making progress right now
that if I was faster I would make an
awkward explosive joke on on C4 boom
goes to Dynamite and you've got a great
move but the point is this was a very
very well-timed move you can put the
bishop on C6 it holds D7 it hits A4
yeah he does it he does I would play H5
I like it yep
the King goes to E3 to
avoid defile with Tempo maybe oh Rook C7
is an excellent move if you take A4 you
go back to A7 picking up the A3 pawn and
then black I think Magnus is potentially
taking over the initiative here you got
to be really careful if you're Wesley
rook h8 and H4 that idea has become
reality Danny and it's happened much
sooner than we all expected H4 is coming
soon to a theater near you
yeah and you still have the problem that
if you grab the pawn The Rook just
swings back here so Wesley oh no trouble
he goes oh no
Magnus is taking over the game Rook a
two if you go to the third round
next yeah oh my gosh Bishop takes A4
Rook takes a three four king the bishop
and the G3 Pawn it's like a knife
through butter how magnus's Rook is
operating in this end game and black is
now winning
this is just fascinating here and again
not not exactly the Magnus measurement
yard stick thing we normally see but it
did eventually turn around we see that
he kept it equal and he's put himself in
a position to maybe win Wesley is also
way down on the clock that turned around
fast
again where was Wesley's mistake now
let's not bury him yet he's still trying
to hold the drug Rook C7 but Bishop
takes C4 Bishop A6 there was maybe
possible now Magnus is likely to push G3
and your issue is that you can't move
the king up to G2 Danny because the
Bishop from C4 moves back to D5 with
check that's why Wesley got his Rook off
of the C file still some chances for
white Magnus has to find the time to
bring his King up to G6 but now that's
hard to achieve
it's gonna say but the problem is that
Rook F2 comes and Magnus found it
okay Wesley holding on but the mating
net now starts to feel very real the
moment this Rook flips around okay
the E5 Pawn yeah yeah I don't think he's
got Wesley is living on the increment
here which is never a place you want to
be against anyone and certainly not the
uh the highest rated player of all time
in Magnus Carlsen good try by Wesley
though targeting the F7 Pawn Magnus down
to one second he's got to keep an eye on
his clock that was a panicky move he got
back with his King
he goes back to d8 now to kick the
bishop out he's going to offer the trade
okay The Rook ending I guess also would
have been losing
God Wesley holding on Bishop E8 and he's
gonna make the draw Bishop takes up
seven
what a stellar defensive move there from
Wesley to get that pawn
okay I don't know that it draws in hand
just yet but it should be as well with
best play now in a classical game Danny
White would even contemplate taking on
E6 but imagine defending rook and Bishop
versus Rook on the increment Magnus is
still trying he's trying to weave some
sort of amazing net but this is going to
be exceedingly hard to achieve Rook F4 I
think wins the pawn and Wesley will save
the game wow
huge boost of confidence for Wesley so
there even though that got away from him
where he was better the fact that he was
objectively lost and somehow snatched
stalemate from the jaws of defeat that's
the confidence you need and we've said
from the beginning for those of you who
are with us we previewed the bleep out
of this thing and one theme remains
consistent throughout Wesley so's career
when he's confident he does things like
win the fish a random world championship
and he does things like winthechess.com
Global Championship when he's not
confident on you he does things like
lose 11 games in a row to Magnus on
chess.com
and man and so that's a huge moment that
he didn't lose those first few games to
start today's match and then you took
the words right out of right out of my
mouth we really complete each other's um
uh sandwiches or sends I mean I'm into
whatever you want to complete I'm here
I would love a sandwich right now but
Wesley you know yet he didn't win that
game and you know he did get that lost
position out of an end game that where
he seemed to be playing for two results
although you're never playing for two
results against Magnus you can lose any
end game to him but this does grant you
a lot of confidence and Wesley might be
telling himself you know wait a second I
actually can save some of these end
gives I can compete with Magnus in the
end game and that was a big practical
boost as we see an old school line of
the night or if this used to be popular
in the 80s and 90s uh this opposite
weird opposite color Bishop middle game
with three pawns on the D file
yeah yeah this is uh funny stuff because
opposite code Bishop end games super
trash opposite code Bishop middle games
if white gets going on the on the light
squares this becomes a very very
dangerous position for black to hold and
uh they have a lot of time on the clock
here which tells me both of these
players at least at least know something
about this one even if they haven't
looked at this theory in a while
yeah this bishop G5 Bishop takes F6 line
uh I think Vladimir kramnik pioneered uh
some of the the ideas in in the early
90s and it's always kind of stuck around
as a good backup system to a more
topical uh responses to the night or if
like Bishop G5 and now of course the
English attack and and six H3 I think
the position is dynamically equal uh
black has good chances to generate
pressure on the queen side the queen
from d8 it can come out to A5 The Rook
from A8 can come out to E8 grabbing
control of the e-file and I'm just not
really seeing White's attack yet
although if Magnus plays H4 and then
sneaks that jeep on up the board Danny
you can't fall asleep either if you're
Wesley on the king side
yeah no it's it's interesting because
objectively White's Pawn storm has more
potential than blacks but there you go
also Weiss pawns are easier to Target
than black so Queen A5 is is super
important for that keeping white off
balance and saying hey look okay if you
go all in for the attack
I may grab this Pawn at some point note
that it's not a thing you really do
right now but uh if you know one example
is if you take with the queen I think
that white can just can just trade and
win material back but okay rookie eight
instead which is the uh the move you
were calling for top engine move rook
ae8 and now H4 is very likely and he
does it and I think Magnus I think we
will see that in game Queen takes D5 I
wouldn't be able to resist that juicy
morsel I think Magnus will trade and
then push G5 and essentially play for
positional compensation in the end game
in the form of a space advantage and
maybe he'll win one of the d uh the
d-pawns back likely the D4 upon draw
likeliest result but given what we've
seen in the end games thus far I'm very
much cautious about making a guess uh
and trying to forecast how what this end
game is going to look like 10 moves from
now
no but you're right Wesley takes the
pawn when it was more appropriate that
when I was highlighting that you
wouldn't take it earlier this Rook was
not on E8 exactly or would have been a
move and so the whole point is now
Wesley has taken the pawn at the right
time
and you know A3
such magnesium you know what he's
thinking about I I swear Magnus is
already trying to set a long-term trap
or this Rook runs out of squares
it's not crazy to think about that
Magnus is Devious right now he wants to
set a long-term opportunity for his
opponent to blunder you and I've said
that a lot he does that better than
anyone in history right create chances
for his opponent to go wrong and let's
just see what happens and A3 is one of
those moves that you can easily look
past but if he wins the game it's going
to be one of the reasons that he did
because he forces Wesley to make a
difficult decision guess what if the
pawn was on B4 right now he would
already be threatening to trap The Rook
with Bishop C4 so these things that
we're mentioning they're not some
far-fetched you know distant possibility
they're the reality that Wesley is
facing and I would go Rook C5 and
Evacuate the rookies missed it before
I guess Wesley wants B5 but can Waco
Bishop F1 and Bishop G2 there oh my gosh
nobody the move before it's exactly what
we said he was going for B4 literally
traps The Rook right now and whether
it's Bishop C4 next or a slow jam right
throw on the Lionel Richie and let's uh
let's enjoy ourselves with some candles
this is slow jam it doesn't matter
Magnus is trapped in the rook and we
knew it was gonna happen when he played
A3 there's also Rook to E1 here to
prepare Bishop before but Wesley is
relying on the Move Rook E3 in response
but white could still play Bishop before
and Danny this is such an instructive
point for newer players right the X-ray
defense Rook h e one Rook E3 and Bishop
B4 you've called it the moment Magnus
played A3 and now Wesley is staring down
the barrel uh of a position where he's
going to be down in exchange
I wish I could play half as good as
Magnus as as well as I predict magnus's
ideas because as soon as he played A3 I
asked myself what would Magnus do and
you started to see the purpose of it
Wesley unfortunately lost his focus by
the way your move rookie one is more
accurate than that Bishop F1 computer
agreed and here comes Bishop B4 X okay
G5 oh my gosh he stops H4 First kicks
the bishop Bishop E4 is next and Magnus
Carlson is trapping The Rook in the
middle of the board unbelievable how
like another game that just makes your
jaw drop open and G5 another one of
those imperceptible moments where Magnus
prevented Bishop takes H4 Danny how many
players if we could briefly pull up an
analysis board instead of G5 how many
players would go Bishop before and
blunder Bishop takes H4 Rook takes C3 D
takes C3 and guess what black pre-moves
E2 and if you take on D5 with the Rook
you actually lose the game
God so that's why he played G5
what a crazy light you just saw there
and so
Not only was G5 necessary or most
accurate to save the H Pawn but I didn't
realize how deep the idea was I'm
showing Donya noraditsky an instant
replay because sometimes you got to
appreciate that's amazing line Dania and
and again a lot of players guilty right
here Yours Truly probably would have
just totally missed that idea and you
know that is crazy it's he's an artist
right and that this is an artist too and
Wesley resigns because there are no
chances he drops the exchange and once
you drop the exchange in that position
he would lose the rest of his pawns
there's nothing left to play for and he
is suddenly in already a two-point hole
and the match hasn't even started yet
it's crazy
yep and it's crazy because like the
analysis the the real-time game review
did say G5 was best but I thought it was
for accuracy to hold the H Pawn I didn't
realize how deep that idea went you
called it Dania what a nice idea Magnus
Carlsen is up two games where have you
been everybody we got 10 000 of you on
YouTube we've got
12 000 Plus on Twitch every one of you
are now Donya neraditsky's personal
friend
man you're gonna make me choke up here
during commentary that's not good
I want more I want to show more lines
you know I don't want to tear up saying
that a bunch of people you've never met
on YouTube and twitch are your personal
friend I thought was going to have you
run screaming the other way but hey
you're you're uh you know no I'm kidding
uh but just just kidding thanks for
making it part of your day give us your
comments we love you chat and um and
Donya where are we at here
we're at a weird nimsovich Larson uh
position now this chat might look at
these moves Knight A3 Knight A5 and we
don't have the time to delve into them
suffice it to say that that is the main
line you often see that arrangement of
knights in this line
uh We've transitioned into something
resembling an English opening where I
think Wesley might actually redeploy uh
his knight from A3 bring it back perhaps
even to B1 and then up to C3 in order to
clamp down on these squares D5 and E4
and then I think the game will finally
take on more standard Contours
particularly if Magnus also brings his
Knight back to C6
what's funny because Magnus is another
piece he'll probably fix long term which
is the bishop on D6 right because the
bishop yeah blocks the Central Pawn who
blocks the bishop Etc so Carlson has an
interesting idea to consider as well
which is how do I fix both the bishop
and the Knight
okay rookie eight and the bishop goes
that way nice right if you play C6 you
take away the square for the Knight so
get the Rook out of here back up the
bishop and fix your structure preparing
for D5 but great Point Danny C6 is how
you would want to play this and then
bring the bishop back in D7 D5 kind of
like the Kopec system if anybody knows
that opening but because you've
positioned your knight on A5 and knights
on the rim are dim you're kind of paying
the price I think Magnus is deciding on
the Move order here he starts with the
rookie eight he's gonna play Knight C6
bishop f8 and eventually we're gonna get
a reverse Sicilian structure if he
pushes D7 D5 uh which is likely of
course Wesley could try to beat him to
the punch but no I think we're going to
get precisely that structure momentarily
okay
yeah Wesley places or not interesting
Magnus he kind of accomplishes a hybrid
of our plans right he goes for the code
back but he doesn't draft his own Knight
the problem with that of course
everybody is that whenever you advance
two pawns two squares right next to each
other you are always making positional
weaknesses and now Wesley has it oh my
God Jesus
to highlight the weak light Square
oh wow damn yeah go ahead no I was just
quickly gonna add that this idea in the
English was popularized by chocolate
mamidyara of uh 10 years ago or so where
he started basically pushing G4 In These
Quiet positions and guess what G5 is not
just a paper tiger it literally traps
the Knight and if black plays H6 H4 and
you've merely thrown oil onto the fire
on the king side but go ahead
dude I got nothing more to add to that I
mean it's like following you you're that
guy who makes a toast at a wedding and
you're like oh my God I got nothing I
can say to follow that toast might as
well make an awkward joke and it reveal
something from the past and humiliate
myself and and get out of here right so
no you're uh your line is really
impressive I I love your point G5 is a
real threat H6 just adds fuel to the
fire
this is actually super awkward and you
saw the eval bar loved it when Wesley
played G4
this is spicy you have to go Rook F back
to f8 I think in order to open up a
parking spot for the night on E8 I mean
and and wow there's no valet parking
here that night will just have to move
back and he plays it because he has he
plays it he plays it what a move by
Wesley so to play G4 and of course right
now these guys are are both playing high
level chess but Wesley's accuracy is
damn near perfect still at 99.8 percent
and Magnus is dipping a little bit to 96
percent Here Comes Wesley with the
attack I want I want a dub I again I'm
not room for anybody but I am allowed to
root for drama in terms of commentary
and I love how Wesley has played this
game so far
I think people may be new to the
commentary should understand that we we
are truly unbiased we are in it for good
chess we love and I personally have the
greatest admiration for everybody in the
SEC but obviously a close match is more
interesting to watch than a blowout and
Magnus takes it in stride he says listen
congratulations you can't my knight back
to E8 but look at all the weaknesses on
the king side that White's created by
pushing the Jeep on how do you exploit
those weaknesses well by opening up the
center and that is precisely what Magnus
is preparing so we might see E4 from
Wesley but then he has to deal with a
big big hole on D4 I would go so far as
to say that black might be seizing the
initiative here if he pushes D5
I love how knowledge just oozes out of
you you like you like break your arm and
knowledge just spills out when you're on
the mic you're when you're on the mic
your chest Rhymes are tight and I want
to point out that Dania just said
something that is very instructive for
everybody when your opponent launches a
flank attack the first instinct you have
to have is can I open the center so
Bishop to C7 and D5 would have presented
a real problem for Wesley now he's he's
kind of forced to play E4 because as
much as this stops it it weakens the
dark squares and here comes Magnus oh my
gosh King F1 you can actually still push
D5 because the Bishop from C8 drops into
H3 with essentially a Checkmate what an
idea and so Wesley might have to block
with the Knight but that's a super
awkward move
dude okay if D5 is playing oh I wanted
to I wanted to drop a brilliant symbol
on D5 and Magnus missed it D5 was better
G5 was better but look at his Knight
he's going into E6 massaging those weak
squares on F4 and he says Wesley how
would you like a knight on F4
threatening Bishop H3 okay good stuff by
Wesley though taking it in stride and
watch out for some sort of Knight F6
check related tactics later down the
line
this is some spicy chest though
regardless of who wins and I'm loving it
H4 okay no but this is horrible
yeah this is getting worse for Wesley by
the second here comes the night here
comes the bishop
oh
whatever Daniel starts making sound
effects instead of words we all get a
little antsy yeah you know it's not
going in the right direction for Wesley
when was the last time you dropped a
whoop
it was it's been a while I'm saving it
for you know the right occasion
I think we're close
yeah okay good F5 is played you called
it the file will open up either by on
poisson or by the old-fashioned way and
Magnus is going to bring the house over
here to the king side
okay but what now you know it's very
much a magnus's style to play a move
like Bishop to D7 here he likes to sit
on the position right A lot of people I
need I need to go for it Magnus he he
likes to improve on the other side of
the board you know B5 maybe
um I think he's deciding on on his
approach right now bingo
I'm proud of myself
no you were right and I'm sitting here
like where did the game go wrong again
Wesley you know E4 yeah he I guess he
panicked there and allowed this bishop
B5 checks sorry I'm just like how did
this game get away from him not that
it's over by any means but he's down
under a minute again Magnus is on the
grind here the f file is
is crying if you're looking at it from
White's point of view the file is crying
and
yeah it's crying Wesley's crying his
clock is crying and and Danny this is
really what people don't always
understand about facing Magnus which
I've had the honor of doing in blitz so
many times you start out with so excited
I get to play Magnus I'm going to bring
my a game a couple of games in you're
questioning the meaning of life and
you're asking existential questions
about you know why you started this
match how is it that you're losing every
game while making reasonable moves you
know how is this possible and then you
come to the conclusion that Magnus is
inhuman that's that is the path that you
always end up taking
yeah
why do I even play chess unfortunately
is how that that can feel oh my God I
wasn't even thinking about the e-pawn
because it's and he just opens up the
e-file
s wow it's so funny how that's the
obvious move but like a little bit
counterintuitive to the first the first
totally I meets brain right Danny taking
away from the center why because the
queen on E7 look at the way his pieces
are in such Perfect Harmony it's like a
symphony of each piece fulfilling a very
specific role and the boa constrictor is
winding its tentacles I don't think a
bow Constructor has tentacles but you
get what I'm saying hey you get it we're
inventing new animals here like the
lighter okay my favorite animal just
happens to be a liger
this should be eight the queen will have
to back up the bishop might even just
come to oh yeah Wesley just resolved
there which by the way if we back up and
just appreciate this is not over at all
Wesley's played really good chess he
just also has played Magnus Carlson
and that's probably the right strategy
like why take another three minutes off
the clock psychologically abusing
yourself because you're in a bad
position and two look at the countdown
clock you just got below 50 minutes for
the first time today right 48 minutes
plus you gotta you get a dub or two here
in the five minute portion Daniel and
this is what Wesley was doing to alireza
in their match right this is exactly
what started happening except alireza is
amazing but Magnus is Magnus right if
you go down five points against him
there's zero guarantees that he takes
his foot off the gas pedal most people
they do subconsciously relax Magnus is
almost the other way around I think
Wesley is like that as well generally
speaking but you get into a big deficit
against Carlson and zero guarantees that
he's gonna give you a single chance
throughout the rest of the match
yeah
yeah it can be ruthless it can be brutal
Wesley is an amazing agreed chat sorry
go ahead no no go ahead a great town
population Mr greens comments written
for both players yeah we're we're
rooting for everyone we're rooting for a
close match and right now I'm openly
rooting for Wesley so to get a dub but
you have to appreciate what's happening
here as a Magnus Carlson fan we've been
watching him do this for for many a moon
as they say scientifically it has been
many a moon since we've seen Magnus
play chess like this and it's it's
amazing
well said and uh we have another another
we have another uh real Lopez where
Wesley has deployed his Bishop uh to A7
much like you do in the Italian and this
position looks much more like an Italian
than a rue Lopez recently we have had a
lot of lines that end up transposing uh
from the two openings and I actually
think we do have a direct transposition
into a line of the Italian
yeah and and again that can often happen
and Rory Lopez when black brings the
bishop to C5 versus the I guess slightly
more traditional Square on E7 The Arc
anglesque Archangel development of the
darksword bishop you can have this same
structure in a lot of Roy Lopez's for
black everyone but that Bishop is over
here so this is an interesting change
gets us in an Italian where black kind
of hopes for some long-term play where
that Bishop is a sneaky kind of spying
ninja in the in the in the long game and
C5 poses serious problems to write in
the center because if you go D5 then
black often pushes C4 and reopens the
diagonal for the bishop Magnus takes a
different approach and keeps the tension
in the center tossing the ball back into
Wesley scored now Wesley has to decide
okay am I keeping the tension or am I
trading one more time on D4 and then
applying pressure on the E4 upon as a
result I think it's in Wesley's style to
keep the tension of the move like Bishop
to B7 and then maybe Rook C8 just trying
to put some put some heat on the queen
side
yep or rookie shout out to chat Tyler
one is coming for Magnus your days at
number one or numbered
tyler1 LOL insert League of Legends
degrading comment by me I'm just kidding
we love we love Tyler one we love his
chess even more than we love League of
Legends Bishop B7 is played here comes
Rook to C8 as you said the structure
changing means that white has the most
obvious Target on the board which is the
isolated D6 Pawn
but often black will get a lot of
pressure against E4 as well although in
this particular one I'm really liking
magnus's chances to go after this Pawn
in a hurry yeah this could get
incredibly tactical because Knight F5
will likely be met with d65 I can
guarantee you this is what Magnus is
calculating right now white pushes E5
black sticks the Knight on e4 and then
you get a very difficult position to
calculate and evaluate you could get a
trade on e4 so Magnus has a lot to
figure out
I was going to say let's look at it
before he did it but then Magnus played
it but let's bring up the analysis board
anyway because after Knight F5 I think
we're gonna get D5 here I don't know
that Wesley has another move to deal
with the pawn so I think this line you
called for Donya will be on the board so
let's look at it before the players get
there
I like Bishop G4
that looks sexy
oh my gosh I love it when you talk dirty
like that I love it when you talk like
that the profit Strikes Again by the way
speaking of the profit where is the
Dania narodisky emote on this palette I
don't mean to call out my entire team
and myself in the process but this this
palette of faces has not been updated in
way too long and we need a danielski
emote ASAP Don yeah I'm on it I'm
literally gonna tell staff right now
clip it and ship it where is the Donya
emote
well thank you Danny I'm again I am just
like how did I do this let's clip that
Donya emote is a must
uh I can't wait it to the send it to the
product room all right we got it we're
all over it all right Donya
um it didn't quite happen so where are
we on the live game okay
which is which is also a completely
reasonable move just eliminating Black's
strongest piece now Magnus is better
here once again I think
yeah a slower move then the bishop takes
E4 Queen G4 forcing Banner but you know
it's also a positional one because
you're highlighting that this Pawn is
actually regardless of a weakness it's
actually not very good where it sits
right because it kind of blocks Black's
pieces and keeps them inactive the one
question I have though Dania is E5 is is
a pawn here and what's going on with
that like like why can't you take it
yeah I'm just like missing tactics uh if
you take it here then there's Bishop
takes A7 and queen D4 I believe forking
the Knight The Rook of the G7 Pawn very
important because that's what happens
your knight from E5
oh if you play Bishop takes C3 Knight
takes C3 which he did by the way the
position on the board currently is takes
takes Queen B6 I don't know exactly why
he couldn't take on E5 there may be also
Queen D4 whatever it maybe Wesley didn't
even know but Magnus gets in your head
he gets under your skin and you start to
trust everything he does is the perfect
move and that's what you really really
want to avoid now Magnus can send his H
Pawn up the board he can eliminate the
Knight on e4 at any moment but then
you're opening up the D file and you're
giving blackstrokes better Prospect so
it's a committal decision to take on e4
here as tempting as it is and he does
he does he does take it 56 maybe yeah
but okay
that's okay all right Bishop takes E4
oh he goes for the end game that's a
little surprising Queen D6
he wants the d-pawn
I'll point out that this Knight may not
be traditionally dominated by a Robert
Hess obligatory three Pawn away but the
Knight doesn't feel very good there if
you trade on D6 and take he lacks a lot
of squares and this d-pawn is dangerous
I'm curious how Magnus is going to
recapture because it's not going to give
him that he takes with the pawn yeah he
can take with the Knight of the tempo
and that Bishop on B7 is gasping for air
Danny Bishop C6 you can Target it with
rook ac1 and then black can take on E5
so there's a lot to calculate there and
that's why Magnus is pausing
and he does think he does take with the
pawn maybe you were right maybe that was
the more accurate approach but I
originally like this because I feel like
if if I'm gonna just put my Rooks here
anyway I've got the d-pawn I've got the
C file
the Knight can come to check at some
point if there's a tactical reason to do
so I.E you want to challenge my file I
fork you so this is just so like so
tough for black to play this great
example of a position where the eval bar
is ridiculously misleading it was
showing equality apparently black had to
find Knight F4 and I'm not saying that
Wesley's lost or anything but it's try
to look at this position with your own
eyes right who would you rather be find
me a single person who says black and
who isn't being you know contrarian
by the way Knight F4 I love that you
said that the engine said that because
sometimes we can learn things from our
computer friends even though they
irritate us the 904 was keyed on you not
just because it fixed the night problem
that I was highlighting this is the best
defensive square but it actually
prevented the Rooks from coming to C1
because of a fork on E2 right Knight F4
was the best move by the by the by
anyone here and Wesley couldn't find it
but now magnus's Knights are going to be
all over by 97 check the other night's
gonna come into D5 and you've got Force
Galore and in Knight B6 yeah and wipes
Rook of course is itching it's itching
to park itself on C7 and oh my gosh I
think Wesley's best chance might be
actually magnus's clock he needs to try
to create practical difficulties for
Magnus who's taking his time trying to
decide which piece he wants to activate
first okay A4 trying to go for activate
the A1 Rook
ha
4 to activate the A1 Rook by the way
Knight 3 to D5 as you called was the
best move there
um all right A4 Bishop D7
this is instructive to get all your
pieces in the game though and I also
just still feel like
this position is just so hard for black
to play you can't challenge the open
file or there are looming tactics
everywhere
okay but this is not going in magnus's
Direction because now Danny Rook 8 d8
okay the Knight can sink its teeth into
D3 then you could put a rook on d8 and
the D6 Pawn could very well turn from a
strength to a weakness maybe it already
has
okay all right yeah Magnus did let this
slip we'll see if Wesley can convert
he's also up on the clock as you already
said
okay now rook d8 and Wesley's making
strides here G6 F5 is an idea to connect
your Pawn chain on the king side hard
for a white to make progress with that
Bishop on B5 so well cemented by The
Pawn on A6
yeah that's that's a really good point
protecting each other the a pawn Keeps
The Rook out of the file and it protects
the bishop to hold down the center light
squares so
this is look okay Magnus down under 10
seconds this is possibly Wesley's chance
to strike absolutely his chance to
strike he's gonna strike with F7 F5 and
then I think Magnus wants to involve
that E3 Knight and maybe bring it up to
C4 and over to A5 so it's not like black
is out of danger but if Wesley Treads
carefully then he should be in the
driver's seat here as he brings his
Knight back and was threatening the fork
on B3 yeah and now maybe Rook have seven
or something like that
I was wondering if we could go after
putting pressure on the pawn just to
keep those pieces stuck and maybe
threatened to take but
okay Rook F7 may be safer well it
threatens is seven
Sorry Seven threatens Rook takes E7
yeah yeah
okay he goes for the move I was saying
but your move was better Rook F7
he takes back the D6 Pawn is getting
closer to falling
okay Rook where does it go rookie six
walks into Knight C7 we could get a
repetition of moves here Knight C7 back
to D5 but Wesley playing for a win and I
think he has to go back to F6 I don't
think oh he won't go to the king and
that looks really risky to my eyes
you can't even take D6 in the end white
with no case back with rookie six check
I wonder if he wanted that and yeah you
look at magnus's Pawn C5 is coming and
he's gonna have connected passers oh no
and you're losing to the fork oh Wesley
throws his hand
oh man not your traditional Magnus
measurement yard stick tool thingy we
see there that game stayed equal for
longer but Magnus does get the job done
as we see he's now being informed that
it is half time here and our five plus
one minute portion the first segment of
today's speechless Championship
presented by coinbase match and there
you have it Dania Magnus is up four
games
that was a really concerning game
because Wesley turned it around he was
up on time he had the initiative and
even with all of the ingredients in
place he still was not able to pull out
even half a point big changes need to be
made by Wesley but let's not sugarcoat
this is a really really difficult
situation after the first half of the
five minute portion Magnus just doing
Magnus things
yeah and I agree this game was
concerning because it had potential and
got away which sometimes feels worse
than games that ran away from you but
all right we still have a lot of Chess
ahead we have the back half of the 5-1
portion don't go anywhere it's more SCC
action when we return
[Music]
almost daily I love them honestly
because they taste great I know that
sounds silly but not everyone wakes up
looking forward to taking a supplement
and I legitimately do because they're
tasty obviously they're phenomenal for
you or I wouldn't be taking them a few
years ago I went completely corn free so
I don't eat anything that has not just
corn but any type of corn syrup which
these days isn't everything and so I
spent a lot of time looking into these
supplements whether it's pre-workout or
just to like start my day
and I spend a lot of time looking into
that stuff and there is nothing better
than the ingredients in it hey
[Music]
phenomenal for
any type of thing you're looking you're
looking for whether it's just adding a
little more whatever you want to call it
fiber vitamins all the stuff in them you
know into your diet if you're lacking
some of that if you're legitimately
looking for energy and and ways to kind
of start your day on the healthy side of
the of the bed if that's a thing or the
chess board but uh no the the
ingredients in this stuff is the highest
quality if you are looking for anything
to boost your diet around it's awesome I
also actually take this liquid stuff
which is vitamin D with vitamin K these
days if you're not taking vitamin K with
vitamin D you're basically wasting your
time if you didn't know that Pro tip you
gotta have vitamin K with your vitamin D
so anyway I uh I love ag1 whatever
reason you might be looking for it
it just tastes so good like honestly I
have to be careful not to drink too much
because then that kid you know could be
too much for your tummy but it's
phenomenal tastes good good for you good
energy makes you feel like you're
starting the day fresh and I recommend
it check out ag1 right now
foreign
let me ask you this you ever feel like
you're undervalued absolutely everyone's
like oh pawns they can only move one
square they can't go backwards new we
don't want to go backwards you know
maybe we're focused on the future yeah I
feel that sometimes I wonder why we're
even protecting a king he wasn't elected
through a democratic process maybe I
want to be king dude I think about that
every day yeah okay real quick shout out
to our sponsor hellofresh I don't use
them because I'm a chess piece but I'm
sure they're grapes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the speed Chess Championship presented
by coinbase continues here on our first
of two semifinals in back-to-back days
he's Dania daradinski I'm Danny wrench
and uh Wesley so is in a hole right now
Donya he's down four games
let's um let's actually just jump right
into it and and see what he had to say
coming into this match in regards to how
he ranked his chances against Magnus
because unfortunately Dania he's already
kind of saying that without the 1-1
portion I have a chance but right now
the 1-1 portion isn't even the problem
your thoughts on how he can turn this
around
yeah it's like the whole you know all
squares are or all all squares are
rectangles but not all rectangles are
squares right in order to have a chance
against Magnus you have to do well in
the first two portions that is like the
initial condition but even if you do
well in the first two portions that
doesn't mean that you're going to win
the match so in order to even have that
conversation Wesley had to get off to a
strong start and he hasn't the opposite
has happened and what's concerning Danny
isn't just the four-point deficit it's
the way that he's losing the games all
four of them were at one point
relatively balanced end games and you
know if Wesley's not pulling out the
games that are going into his types of
positions then you know that just makes
it even more concerning
yeah well and it's hard it's hard to
beat Magnus when Magnus is Magnus and
he's and he's ready and I guess his
quote is ultimately going to prove right
about facing Wesley so as we see there
which is Magnus said I think if my if my
game is on form he's gonna have to play
very good just to keep it exciting well
guess what right now I think all the
fans would like Wesley so to play very
good to keep this thing exciting because
he's down four games he knows what he's
up against and uh Magnus apparently has
something that he forgot speaking of
what he's up against right don't forget
your snacks don't forget you there you
go Magnus yeah all right I think he
forgot to fold his clothes in the
background Falls you know that's it's
been a thing we've seen we've been
talking to Magnus about that you know
the clothes in the background they're
meant to be put away let's not be left
on the couch I leave them in the dryer
and then I pull out individual articles
of clothing for weeks at a time
the dryer becomes the dresser in
bachelor life we get it um bachelor life
left me a long time ago but that is
another story rated R Memoir coming your
way all right but we've got these two
guys they're both sitting they're both
ready
we uh we I'll go back to what you said
because it's how he's lost these games
not that they've been landslides it's
that he's lost very close games done it
almost makes it worse right he's not
even converting when he has a chance and
and that's a problem it definitely makes
it worse because if you're losing by one
move blunders and yeah technically he
lost the last game with a one move
blunder but it was already bad if you're
losing because you're not getting out of
the opening or you know you're
blundering you can make active changes
you can steer the game in a different
direction you can change your openings
but when the problem is occurring below
the surface when you're getting what you
want and then still losing it makes it
harder to make in match adjustments and
I'm really curious how Wesley's gonna
handle uh you know the most difficult
moment of his SCC run thus far as we see
a very tactical uh rosalimo Sicilian
with a B takes C6 variation Danny it's
more common to take with the d-pawn to
open up the light Square Bishop but
Magnus I think just going for the kill
yeah and he's playing a very sharp line
but objectively is is is pretty good for
white we see that only pawns have moved
here for black because the Knight was
traded white has a big Center a queen in
the middle of it and peace is coming so
objectively white is a little better but
it's not just said it's kind of more
Magnus going for the kill here because
this is one of those games that's going
to be super double edged and if he gets
another victory in a really sharp
Sicilian having chosen I'll just quickly
show it to play B takes C6 here instead
of the D take C6 more solid lines then
that could really spell more disaster
for so here comes E5 for Magnus okay
what a wild one we're gonna have here
and we're likely gonna get that G8
knight uh Ferry it over to F7 Knight G8
to H6 to F7 is very standard uh in this
line and then Magnus has to make sure
that he's covering all of the weak
squares in his position I mean obviously
his structure is a little bit flimsy but
it simultaneously flimsy but also very
very solid if you imagine the black Pawn
on D6 he's got this whole D6 E5 F6 G6
Pawn cocoon that does make it difficult
for a white to infiltrate I actually
think that if both sides are able to
complete their development Danny we
might switch from a tactical battle to a
more positional game by the way Knight
takes E5 here needs to be calculated I
don't think there's any chance of
working but that might be what Wesley's
thinking about as he drops his Queen to
C3
I I think we should analyze that real
quick I I want to show on the analysis
board because I think especially for
most of the viewers Knight takes E5 is
the tactic that it's like wait is this a
puzzle Rush moment an A5 Knight takes E5
just point out the problem is that if
you take take we have a little shake and
bake and The Rook is hanging but the
issue is when you take on E5 always look
for your opponent's threats before you
assume a tactic Works Queen A5 check
actually just picks up a piece oh so
anyway
so that's why I played Queen C3 now he's
actually threatening Knight takes C5 and
Magnus Magnus can't play Knight H6 here
which is the the move you want to play
so I think he's gonna have to go Bishop
G7 or go Knight E7 or D6 maybe because
of that threat
or Rook to B8 Oh Daddy what are you
preparing then why can't I take on E5
there hey you know I uh I just brought
those little tricks today Danny tricks
are for kids
um
no but I'll add something else what you
said because I think if black does
develop you you pointed out that Black's
position is a very solid but I'll say
it's also very flexible and let's not
forget that black has the bishop pair
that's probably what you gained in order
to lose development and if a position
slowly becomes more and more open
whether that is on the queen side with
diagonals whether it's with D5 what
you're counting on is that black
actually has the better minor pieces
despite those pieces being undeveloped
at this time and the other the other
problems so wow the word Danny that
comes to mind when I look at D5 is
brazen I think that's the best word to
describe what Magnus doing right not a
single piece developed and the guy is
opening a center allowing Queen C6 Jack
which would cause most people to reject
D5 on the spot but obviously he's looked
one step further Bishop D7 and I think
he's gonna try to get his pieces out
quickly but Magnus didn't do this
because he liked his position he
actually did it because he thought it
was necessary uh to supercharge his
development even at the cost of a pawn
yeah
yeah he did hang the pawn white is
better materially which is why you see
that edge there but again I want to I
want to say he did it because he's like
well my only real strength in the
position is the Bishops let's get an
open position where there's some play
and maybe some tactics if white plays
best this this really should be maybe
the first win for Wesley so fingers
crossed but otherwise Magnus is looking
for activity for the Bishops
okay so Bishop G7 here is the obvious
move but Magnus thinking I think about
Bishop to B5 also uh preventing light
from castling and this is what you got
to do in a bad position you got to make
these micro problems for your opponent
also to try to get him to burn clock
imagine's burning his own clock right
now
Queen A5 check and queen A6 I think is
his idea yeah same concept he likes he
likes your idea but with a different
piece that moves diagonally you know
which one would that be not the best I
was gonna say there's only well actually
there is three one that captures
diagonally but the scientific
breakthrough is that they have combined
the rook and the bishop together and it
is called the queen oh interesting I
like the way you're thinking right now
and will when will this piece make its
debut and uh you know I in modern I've
heard I've heard it's coming
your way to a chessboard near you rook
and Bishop have combined together fun
fact Danny really quickly before we
analyze this end game the queen used to
be the weakest piece on the board and
the old person an Indian form of Chess
called shot Raj the queen it would move
one square diagonally in any direction
and the Russian word for queen is fierce
which is not actually a Russian word it
only means chess Queen and it comes from
the Persian for vizier because the queen
actually used to be a male figure uh in
ancient Persia the king's closest
advisor was called the vizier and that
is why the vizier was weaker than the
king because the hierarchy had to be
preserved and then when chess came to
Europe partially due to the influence of
Queen Isabella the queen became the most
powerful piece on the chessboard okay we
have a game to analyze I apologize
amazing chess history lesson and I knew
those things but it's fun to hear
someone frame it in a different way and
uh yeah I mean Queen Isabella changed
the game for the queen and now now she's
the most dominant
is dominant
D5 is dominant once he's up a whole Pawn
like this is not even a problem with
compensation as Yasser would say it's a
pawn and the compensation it is a
two-on-one majority
you convert this game now or Dania walks
out of here Wesley let's you have to
convert that I mean this is you have to
convert this game and Danny step on the
gas pedal plate I don't like B3 I
thought Rook ac1 might have been almost
winning on the spot because that Rook
was infiltrating to C7 you gave up B2
with Chuck but the king would have
dropped back to F1 this gives Magnus the
tempo he can use it to try to cover all
of the holes in his position and
ultimately jump to B4 with his Knight if
he can eliminate Wesley's D5 Knight the
technical task facing Wesley becomes all
that much more difficult
yep
no that's totally true this was a
defensive move rather than best defense
as a good offense
Wesley has to keep the pressure here
especially before black completes
development right you want to play Tempo
moves when your opponent is off balance
and uh you got to keep the pressure here
by the way Rook ac1 still just has to be
with the doctor ordered here let's get
our pieces actively making threats but
I'm still harping on that moment where
Wesley could have played Rook C1 two
moves ago and gotten his Rook to the
seventh rank now I think we're gonna see
Knight before and we do Wesley wants
Knight C4 perhaps and we're gonna get
some sort of transformation if if Magnus
takes on D5 and then maybe goes Rook D7
and starts going after the D5 Pawn
mm-hmm
it's still a good position for Wesley
but I agree you hate having those games
where you keep saying things like Ah
that's still okay but it's not as good
as it could have been oh you're still
winning but maybe not as winning as you
were those are not words that you want
to have come out of a commentator's
mouth
no definitely
all right Bishop D7 played Wesley is
still better again even if not as good
as it maybe could have been I think this
transition has been helpful
for for white
yeah he should win this game Knight A5
Knight C6 is a big idea I think I
wouldn't be able to resist the
temptation Knight A5 also opens up the
pathway to the C7 Square Magnus might
respond with a check on B5 but then the
King has actually the F3 Square which is
very important and we yeah bring it the
high John G3 the king is safe and you
know I think he's also going to push uh
A4 on the queen side I think Wesley back
on track here
agreed A4 nice C6 to move even even D6 a
move at some point where you're
threatening Rook C7 and just kind of
getting straight forward and jiggy with
it over there D6 Rook C7 A7 will fall at
the end of the line so there's a lot of
a lot of pressure coming to Magnus who
now is under 40 seconds on the clock
from a distance I think Magnus might
have been relying on G4 check and it's
kind of a cutesy move you can't really
take on G4 because of the fork on E2 but
the king can hide amongst the trees
there on G3 and black is way too slow to
generate King side counter play I think
we might see G4 just for just for good
measure but that's that's not gonna
create a counter play that that
seriously countervails what's going on
on the queen side I think this might be
Wesley's first win okay E4 but I think
you can actually take that
yeah I think I think you kind of need to
because it's harder to hide in the trees
if you don't take it yeah no more
trouble yes yeah speaking of trees don't
get don't yourself mated
so Bishop comes to E2
you can just move the Rook I think
if he does
yeah okay now Knight C6 get the E7
Square so that there's no nasty little
check with a rook I would go Knight C6
prophylactically
I was looking at there was a way to
punch the pawn there really isn't
tactically yet you don't want to do that
so if the king is in danger Knight C6 I
love it it also by the way does threaten
the A7 but watch the clock this is
exactly what Magnus wants if it gets
into a Time scramble black has practical
chances rooksy had an excellent
alternative
Knight C6 now and I think Wesley a
couple of accurate moves away as Magnus
tries to prepare F5 check
what a simplifying move oh King E3 is so
nice The Rook defends the bishop on C5
no discovery
and go back to E4 now after this check
just sits pretty in the center I love
Bishop C5 even if Knight C6 was better
what a nice way to simplify the game if
you're Wesley so just take it you're
eliminating tactics
and that was so nice to Annie how he
took the bishop on C5 you could have
also taken the Rook that was a lot more
complicated this is much easier to play
Rook E2 just don't give up that D5 pawn
and you're golden
yep
it's not over yet but Wesley so converts
this
it is it has been the most complete
start to finish game for him in the
match and and a very good sign for
Wesley cell fans out there really only
one mistake to not play Rook AC one gave
Magnus some practical chances but after
that Wesley never looked
never looked back and look at how he
finishes the game counter-attacking The
Rook the final release move and we see
Wesley so
breathing a bit of a sigh of relief
right there if you caught him on camera
he was like he's like I will take that
Victory I'm looking for an emote that
expresses that is it that one no that's
an OMG one is it this one I don't know
maybe he just
I don't know he's just feeling better
about the position
by the way Wesley cell
we're okay everybody
no comment I can't do all that
newfangled emote stuff Danny I'll leave
that to the uh to the younger generation
you know the younger generation because
you're so old
um
all right well Wesley so does win
and it is a three-game lead currently
for Magnus Carlson
back to uh what what actually what's
this this is another Roy Lopez but uh
but a Berlin move order a little
different than what we've seen before
that was the conditions when you know
the passport control officer was
stamping Wesley's passport he's like
okay I'm letting you in the country as
long as you play the Berlin at least
once against Magnus Carlsen in your SEC
match and he did and Magnus going for
the anti-berlin with D3 but I don't
think he's gotten much here unless
unless he pushes F4 that might be his
only chance to spice things up on the
king's side otherwise it's just dead
equal
yeah
oh and he does have four but it's easy
to blunder Danny ef4 Rook F4 would be a
very instructive blunder maybe we can
show that because if Bishop takes B3 and
Knight D5 okay Wesley taking a different
approach
um so we don't have to but but I'm gonna
I'm gonna quickly show it when we have a
second here the idea Dania pointed out
is hard to see sometimes when there's
smoke you can't you can't kind of see
through it but if he takes M4 Brook
takes F4 black can trade and no matter
how you take back on B3 there is a
knight four Card round the world on D5
and we have material beautiful so there
you go this this was not not to be
blundered by Magnus instead we're headed
toward an end game okay but yeah that
was a nice find Donya yeah and I
actually think Wesley should have taken
on F4 because now he's got another end
game in the in the category of the the
person you want this end game against
the least is Magnus Carlson and the
person you're facing right now is Magnus
Carlson
yeah this is these are the kind of games
that lead to the Magnus measurement
stick oh meter I think I might say it
differently every time but when we see
that game Mark the Magnus measurement
stick a meter he tends to follow a very
consistent path he keeps his games equal
not a lot of crazy up and down in the
opening and especially early middle game
stages but he grinds you out and and uh
this is the kind of game that Magnus
wins a lot of and black is worse why for
two main reasons the first is the B6
Pawn long-term Target that was the
reason Magnus played A4 to fix that pawn
because it's harder to shoot at a moving
Target right if that pawn landed on B5
it would have been a better defend and
now second reason Superior activity of
White's night night C4 and the Knight is
aiming at the B6 spawn and that is
precisely why Wesley plays 98 he's
trying to get his own Knight to D6 so a
trade of knights here I think would help
black uh reduce White's advantage to a
minimum Rook A6 here very important and
B4 is tempting but I think Wesley's in
time to get his Knight to D6 and kick
its vis-a-vis out of its dream Square
yeah if you're white you wish you had
time to do other things to Target the
pawn but that's just not a reality with
the Knights being traded in addition to
the fact that the A4 opponents weak
so B4 makes go ahead no no I was gonna
propose A5 but go ahead yeah I I I was
just gonna propose A5 like I'm not
kidding I was gonna propose apan I was
gonna propose A5 okay no but I really
was gonna propose it because it was even
though you let black trade the weakness
everyone the whole idea was that if
there's a is if there's a trade you end
up exposing a different issue which is
that maybe Black's pieces are all kind
of oddly coordinated with the Rooks of
the six rank so Magnus doesn't go for
that but A5 might have actually been a
really nice idea now he has to ask the
question
how do I keep the knights on the board
or or am I allowing The Rook ending in a
White's position I think is still a
little bit preferable after the night
trade but Wesley shouldn't have problems
holding the draw he can also play F6 uh
building up that nice king-site Pawn
chain and opening up a pathway
completing each other's sandwiches again
King goes up to E6 and I just don't see
the kind of action on the queen side
that would cause Wesley to Shake in his
boots
a Greektown population US
I don't think he's wearing boots in our
hotel room but anyway
you know I do get it I do get it
um
yeah Magnus taking his time here down a
little bit on the clock
but he knows that it's kind of now or
never in this particular game so a good
time management to really slow down
before you either make the critical
exchange or decide there's enough
chances to justify avoiding it lessons
for the kids watching don't speed
through trades take your time on trades
big time and Magnus could drop back to
E3 I think he's contemplating that move
but he also could end up being worse
because the A4 Pawn is targetable by
Black's other Rook Rook E8 Rook A8 and
guess what now it's white who's
suffering on the queen side and we saw
Wesley lose a game completely different
type of game remember that game where
Wesley played G4 and he was attacking
and it was all great and then suddenly
when you're pushing your pawns you're
creating targets and if your opponent
kind of repels the initial wave of
attack as Wesley has here you have to
make sure that you're managing uh
effectively the weaknesses that you left
behind and I think Magnus going for the
bailout approach here Rook A5 is a super
nice move by Wesley not giving up the a
file
wow
what a very nice move if you take you
fix my pawns I can easily then defend
them if you don't take then not only am
I threatening the beep on but I own the
I own the file so
it's actually a phenomenal defensive
approach there from Wesley that is now
more of an aggressive one he saw this
coming he's up a minute plus here on the
clock
I'm just saying you know stranger things
have happened than the revitalization of
Winona Ryder's career in a Netflix TV
show show you that you didn't see coming
stranger things have happened maybe
Wesley so gets the dub okay I just got
that took me did you did you know that I
said the word revitalization can someone
is that a word it's definitely a word
everything's over Danny everything okay
revitalization the action of imbuing
something with new life and vitality not
only did I use it correctly it was the
right thing to say that happened to
Winona Ryder's career
I love it when you look up a word it's
like a Ferrero Rocher candy and then
there's that little Hazel Knight in the
middle there's another SAT Word that's
waiting for you in the definition imbued
that's a good one as well Magnus says
Pawn structure uh with a sense of I have
no idea where I'm taking this is
defending all of his pawns and I think
we're heading in the direction of a draw
here but not for sure because maybe G5
happens and the King side opens and
things get tactical so I wouldn't hang
my hat on on you know the result things
or Rook takes C4 by the way easy thing
to miss
that's actually really key it's the the
weird way to use a rook a rook piano
Rook is pinning a pawn
or is that a skewer I don't even know
but I know it's off the board now
because we have G5 there is a threat of
taking C4 hold on
but black has no time because Jeep takes
F6 and okay black would get chocolate on
King's side so I would take once on G5
and actually make sure that my
king-saipan structure is well protected
but then white takes in Rook F2 Danny
it's actually crazy can we bring up the
analysis board because Donya just kind
of let it slip that there might be a
Checkmate but we should actually show
that like if you take on C4 and there's
some sort of take take shake and bake uh
this Rook is coming to G2 and you're
getting mated on the edge of the board
in shockingly quick fashion so that was
actually really important to keep an eye
on there I just wanted to show that no
absolutely two Rooks are more than
enough material to generate a mating
attack yeah and Magnus poking and
prodding on the king's side he's
definitely playing this for a win but
King E6 and Rook D7 I mean realistically
with 90 seconds this this should not be
too difficult for Wesley to hold
yeah it shouldn't be but time pressure
does strange things to a man and right
now
if both sides get into mutual scramble
it's anyone's game Rook A7 is not a
happy move to play but it was maybe the
only thing to do I would have gone Rook
D7 but I think Wesley actually is afraid
to trade a pair of Rooks Because he
believes that in the ensuing position
with all of White's pawns protected
maybe he'll have some trouble defending
his own weaknesses on B6 and F6 but I
don't think he's got anything to be
concerned about even in this position
with that passive Rook Rook A3 now this
was this was a nice move too because you
can come back to A3 anytime and if white
tries to get too Jiggy over here and
maybe Checkmate the black king you get
mated yourself so I agree with you the
more I look at this
I I think a draw has to be the most
likely result they're going to continue
to play tickle for a little while here
but huge weakness for white equally big
weak pawns for black means that both
players are a doll boy right all working
no play
Yeah Boy tell me you got that one
I did not
I laughed but I didn't
I'm laughing almost at my own inability
to grasp these rounds no you're great
that's a that's a good that's a good one
though all right rookie eight the king
is now coming to C5 which by the way is
fun because you get your king out of
trouble and maybe guard B6 but the
problem is if you go too far then then
you got other problems so yeah this is
just
we're just playing footsie here don't
want to turn into Icarus here and you
know come fly too close to the queen
side because okay but Wesley's playing
for a win I think he's feeling lucky
after that last game
no he's not he's like
no I'm not I love it you were trying to
set the tone unless he's playing for win
it had to be Rook D6 if he really was
but now without he might lose it as you
said Icarus flies a little too close to
the Sun you regret it so let's stay away
from that he decides to tuck his tail
between his legs and settle on the draw
and uh
no I've I've read The Shining people in
the chat I haven't seen The Shining but
I have read the book I'm a huge Stephen
King fan so my brain is just too puny to
hold all the literary characters I've
read about in my mind as we see our
first draw of the match
or we get eight no second it's our
second yeah game remember game two was
that actually very impressive oh yeah
Wesley held that end game which we
thought at the time was going to be
super critical Wesley did go on to lose
the next few but I I think that uh a
draw is still not a bad result for
Wesley he has officially stopped the
bleeding in the last two games
and who knows maybe he gets a win as
white and keeps this thing close
okay Carl Khan we haven't had a Karo
Khan yet I always like new openings in
the SEC and Wesley responding with an
ultra solid uh exchange Caro this this
has been very very popular it's a good
way to fight for the advantage and this
structure also occurs as some people in
the chat will will know in the London
system in fact you could get a direct
transposition uh from the Karo Khan
exchange line to the London
yeah and you know how we feel about the
London we do not very positively
I tried to delete the London from the
game of chess in a video we did last
week unfortunately turns out it wasn't a
good idea but all right
um sorry Eric
yeah there you go although today there
was something huge on social uh that
there's like a Rosen score which ranks
the possibility for tactics and and
weird ways to trick your opponent
um so shout out to Eric Rosen and his
ability to break people's hearts
with obnoxious chess
did I say that right
I think you said it perfectly Annie
you know what else is perfect at night
on E5 which can't be capable it is
because that is
that is a unicorn of a pony
and if you take it white takes back with
the pawn you get kind of a new square at
times for the other night potentially at
this at this point of course it's it's
not even an option because you would
lose a piece but
yeah that is a beautiful night and
Black's arteries are kind of clogged
here though the way you play here with
black is you work around this night but
it's not Pleasant now if you really want
to eliminate it then you need to drop
your queen back or your F6 Knight back
to D7 which we might see and that
directly challenges the night I actually
would have dropped the queen back to C2
in order to prevent the F6 knight from
moving back
but I wonder what Wesley Cooks up
against Knight D7 here maybe it's F4 but
F4 is always a committal move in such
positions because you are weakening the
E4 square but Danny with that Knight on
D2 Bishop on D3 and Rook on E1 I
absolutely think Wesley can get away
with F4 if he wants to right now there's
no real necessity to play that move
yeah it's a it's a great point I'm also
trying to anticipate what was the idea
of A3 I'm like I'm trying to imagine
opportunities where the queen comes to
B4 because if that trade happens the a
file opens up so maybe Wesley was sort
of prophylaxis thinking about that idea
down the road otherwise it is a very
kind of strange not very aggressive move
um and
yeah I don't I don't quite know Magnus
played Rook C8 great move you might say
why is he putting the Rook on a closer
semi-closed file because Queen C2 there
was impossible due to Knight takes D4 so
the queen on B3 very weirdly is almost
stranded on the queen side can't go back
to D1 can't go back to C2 and instead
Wesley banking on his other pieces
preparing to double Rooks on the e-file
I still like his position but I think
Magnus is doing a great job of working
around the Knight on E5
yeah
you called it working around the pony
now it should I was gonna say now I was
gonna say it should be noted for the
first time you could take it because
you're no longer getting forked and
before I could even complete the
sentence Magnus does take it which is
interesting right he gets rid of the
strong Knight after takes he will put
his Knight on wait you're just gonna go
back or is he gonna
you gotta get spicy in here that's
what's giving Wesley Paws you know mo 99
of the time you recapture with the phone
automatically here you have to calculate
Knight G4 and Magnus is going to pause
here as well it's more up his alley to
play Knight D7 and Bishop G6 but if he's
feeling brave yeah you know which he's
not in this position he would have
gotten ig4
which definitely feels like the human
call this is a very scary move to play
it might have been the best move
actually but all right Knight D7 now
you're gonna put the bishop on G6
quickly
wait Queen B4 Queen H4 is a really nasty
idea Danny sorry to interrupt uh if the
age file opens
you can interrupt anytime if you're
talking about sweet nothings on the king
side I love that idea that is a mating
net that I am happy to see
and
I think Magnus has to take back with the
F Pawn again this is if he plays Bishop
G6 that would be so painful 1965 by the
way Bishop takes H7 check talk about
painful
yeah let's let's bring up the analysis
board because we got some critical ideas
to show in this moment first of all if
Bishop G6 takes Don just pointing out
that you kind of have to take with the
F1 because if you take with the H Pawn I
think the first thing white does is
defend the pawn Donya but this H file is
going nowhere and you are in
very very dangerous territory so if you
take with the F Pawn
that is ugly a f yep
I think I'm allowed to say that I think
you are too and instead Knight takes C5
let's just very quickly show yeah
counter-attacking the bishop runs into
Bishop takes H7 check King H7 Rook H5
forking the other night it's so
aesthetically pleasing when you do this
you take one minor piece and then you
Fork another in the process and Magnus
with a drastic G6
wow
holy Fork balls he's in trouble and he
knows it he plays G6 and now Rook comes
back to E3 which I love this move from
Wesley especially that he played it
quickly maybe there was something better
Johnny but he quickly knows just how
devastating this move is for black the
bishop is trapped it's ugly and he's
like I'm not gonna sit here and try to
find a concrete win I'm gonna defend my
e-pawn black is down on the clock and
down on the position that is a very
strong practical move to make so quickly
absolutely and look at that Bishop on H5
look at it carefully because it might
not last too long Queen B4 earlier you
were playing that move to Ferry the
queen to the king side and now you would
be playing this move to prepare G4 and
with the pawn on G6 it's actually very
hard to find alternate arrangements for
the bishop you're not going to go G5
here are you I mean that's that looks
like a devastating weakening of the king
side so you might have to get the Queens
off the board with Queen to B6 but white
could also Danny play H3 and reinforce
the threat of G4 Magnus is walking on
hot coals right now and he might get
burned
yeah
I I agree with everything you said
especially your eloquent choice of words
the metaphors he might get burned at
this point I am all in
and uh I I think he is going to I think
he he might get more than burned right
this uh this is gonna be a problem here
I think Wesley so is going to get his
second win
and after H3 the one bright spot for
Magnus is he can play G5 there G5 is a
much less scary move to play if the
Queens are off the board
um and at that point he has no choice
because you're either losing a minor
piece or you're weakening your king and
you know definitely the second is the
the letter lesser evil uh Wesley could
also drop his Bishop back to C2 that
would be a very much a move in his style
uh to to prevent the black knight from
having that Escape Route uh in in terms
of taking the bishop so tough decisions
here for Wesley and I think he senses
this is a pivotal game he wins another
one and the lead suddenly becomes or the
deficit I should say suddenly becomes
manageable can he contain his nerves and
keep playing as accurately as he has
early in this middle game
agreed I love the move Bishop C2 and it
is awfully Wesley so-esque ish and uh
and yeah I mean G5 will be a move that
is forced at some point to save The
Bishop's life but it might be more than
weakening the king it might also just
lose the G5 Pawn right in some positions
where you can go after it and so
um
yeah Wesley in the driver's seat I think
he knows it
um Magnus feel a little parched and he
clearly knew it took a sip of whatever
that beverage is
and uh here we go he does take it he's
gonna go straight he does okay G5 we're
gonna see but Magnus could take the
bishop I would not take the bishop first
I would go G5 straight away yeah and you
know I think that considering all of the
things that could have happened after
Magnus yeah the 18th move G6 this is you
know it's it's bad but it's a manageable
kind of bad and now he's suddenly up on
time as well
I agree it feels like
Wesley stole a slight advantage in a
position where he had a clear one and he
still is I think in the driver's seat
but it could have been worse for Magnus
for sure
Here Comes D4 by the way talk about
counter play mm-hmm
and we've seen these games turn around
not just 90 degrees Danny but 180
degrees Magnus is definitely thinking
about taking over the initiative and D4
is the perfect moment to do that now
he's gonna go Bishop G6 I think to set
up a night infiltration to D3 his Bishop
ironically is now the safest piece on
the board and it's White's Bishop on B5
that's out of the game completely
wow what a twisted turn of events there
poetic description from Dandy the bishop
is self-trapped with this move C4 very
nice move you're gonna put the Knight on
D3 maybe even right away maybe you take
back first but okay he does there's all
kinds of problems here for white all
sorts of problems rookie two black has a
draw in his pocket Magnus could drop
back to F4 with his Knight and keep
repeating moves he's gonna do it at
least once I think and then decide just
do I want to go for the win here with
something like H5 I don't think so I
think Magnus should go for the draw and
take what he can get here half a point
is great but that's why Magnus is
sitting at that chair and playing and
not me that just goes for it he's like
yeah
I appreciate the caution Tanya I'm gonna
go for it
how about going after the beat two Pawn
Danny yeah why can't you just take and
take B2 I think that that's a problem
um
because this Pawn is out of control it
doesn't matter what you win with check
your Bishop isn't playing it's blocked
by your own Pawn the d-pawn runs dancing
Donna baby girl Donna on D1 bring on the
lady D1 can be used also as a Transit
point for the Knight Knight D1 back to
C3 try them on try that on for size how
about that how you like them apples huh
you like them apples four seconds for
Wesley he's losing control of the game
again
Knight C3
Knight C3 and Tanya unfortunately
94 Knight D2 Fork it's a double Fork
here no here I gotta grab the emote
before they rematch I did it boom boom
and just like that
oh my gosh by the way fun fact fun story
the other day I was in a hotel room by
myself in Paris was there for a little
event with Clash Royale supercell and I
decided to watch uh Goodwill Hunting in
French it was on the TV
what a wild experience that was great
movie how you like them apples watching
it in French when you know every line
just wanted to share that
pretty incredible story that is amazing
that is my favorite scene from that
movie I I like them apples
unfortunately for Magnus oh sorry for
Wesley so fans Magnus Carlson loves them
apples and he gets a victory one that he
he really shouldn't have had uh
necessarily but he increases his lead
once again back to four games and I
don't know what's going on in this game
we've got some sort of ridiculous
amounts of trades in the center
wait D4 oh and I guess black moves the
night back from E5 and saves the minor
piece man I'd have to change my pants
before I did that but looks like Wesley
is gonna get out of the opening here at
least
but this is so debilitating gaining it's
so difficult to bounce back after a game
like that because you do everything
right you play a great strategic game
you outplay Magnus in the middle game
the moment the Queens come off the board
it's like a switch comes on and within
10 moves black suddenly has a past D
Pawn the position becomes totally
unrecognizable
yeah I'm still replaying how quickly
that went away and unfortunately so was
Wesley so we see him
shaking his head at times
um
and uh
what's going on here can I show an
announcing line
yeah sorry let's bring up the analysis
board because I do want to quickly show
this I was busy telling stories about
Goodwill Hunting in French but we had a
Berlin with Bishop C5
so many nights hanging so much fun what
do you what can you teach me about this
Donya well there's an amazing tactic
here Bishop takes D7 check I think
Knight C6 for that reason was the more
accurate Retreat because this would have
prevented what will be an absolutely
sick tactic and I think Magnus might
find it so if we go back to the current
position uh yeah go ahead yeah
no what is it it's Bishop takes D7 check
and you're taking B7 with Tempo Bishop
takes D7 Queen takes B7 and you're
hitting both the rook and the bishop
winning a pawn
and black is in trouble and if you take
back with the King then the king is
exposed and the queen is able to slide
over to F5 hitting the bishop laterally
Queen F5 track King C6 Danny I think the
line continues and I guess we play Queen
F3 check to keep the Queens on the board
and then you recapture the bishop what
an opportunity that was for Magnus
I think he might have sensed that there
was something to be found but instead
he'd ultimately acquiesces to what it is
still probably a smidge better uh
position in the end game because he's
got the slightly more active pieces
oh wow what a tactic that would have
been
fascinating Bishop takes D7 I always
love it when we're analyzing games Donya
um you know two of the best players in
the world before move 10 and guess what
there is new information on the board
right regardless of how we got there in
awkward openings or with computers
revealing tactics that otherwise humans
might miss including humans like Magnus
Carlsen I think that's one of the most
amazing Parts about the game of chess
right it is it is so rich with with New
Roads to travel even before move 10 we
saw a potential crazy new idea in an
opening we see all the time
it's like that you know that that
Robert's uh frostbone The Road Not Taken
it's not just what we see on the board
but it's also what remains behind the
scenes uh that land chess its beauty and
you know you gotta Berlin you never
expect something as tactical as we got
in this game but it you know chess
always throws you in for a loop and
speaking of getting thrown in for a loop
I wasn't expecting Agnes to lift up his
King side pawns like this I mean has he
forgotten that the Queens are off the
board
he did it he was rushing the pawns but
maybe not with the intention of a
Checkmate attack I quickly highlighted
before Wesley played H6 that G5 was the
threat okay now Wesley's offering a
trade no but this
Bishop is in trouble if I keep this
bishop on the board I don't know where I
move it
but
there's there's weird weird ways that
that Bishop runs out of squares here
yeah at some point Bishop G5 is like me
coming up to a food court in an airport
and you know looking at all the
establishments and being like nope but
Magna says yeah give me that greasy
piece on G5 I don't love that decision
from Carlson because now Wesley can play
F6 he can solidify the position and I
think he's on the path to stabilizing I
still think he's slightly worse he's
very passive and maybe Magnus is just
coasting he just says I want to chill in
the same game I want to mitigate my risk
this is the last game of the five minute
portion let me make sure that I don't
lose it
by the way I think you're right Bishop
G3 was better so just in the future if
you're ever questioning yourself should
I engage in the greasy food buffet or
not keep making the decision to not
engage in the greasy Buffet Donya
because even Magnus shouldn't have taken
their
all right but as you pointed out we are
done with the five minute portion after
this a short break and the three minute
portion ladies and gentlemen so don't go
anywhere Wesley so has been
objectively the best player in three
minute chess in speed Chess Championship
history this is his time control if he
can shake it off right Taylor Swift
style we may still have a match so don't
go anywhere
don't go anywhere Wesley has shown Signs
of Life Danny I mean what's I as I said
it's not only the fact that he lost the
previous game but the fact that yes he
had some some momentum and he was close
to making this a three-point match
suddenly it's up to five and that sounds
completely different Magnus by the way
he's not just sitting there and making a
slow passive draw he's still playing
this end game for a win trying to get
his Knight over to G6 and really
clamping down on Wesley in the center
and on the king side
yeah Wesley trying to stop Knight G6 you
could still go forward but I don't know
the Magnus well I think he'll sit on the
position because F4 is also a great home
for the night not just as not just to
keep poking at G6 but to open up E6 as
an opportunity
so
so yeah I think I think this makes sense
doubling Rooks on the e-file another
easy low hanging fruit way to improve
your position and black has to get that
Rook off of E8 until it gets pinned uh
by White's double the e-rooks
yeah the one thing you have to be
careful about if your Magnus is Wesley
quickly switching over here to the H
file
so Carlson is pausing a moment for
station identification this is the
chess.com radio network welcome to the
speech test Championship presented by
coinbase well done
yeah Magnus taking that pause thinking
it through
like 92 Knight F4 and I like it for the
reason you highlighted because it covers
the H3 square and it ensures the
stability the long-term stability of the
King on G3 I wonder what magnus's other
candidate move is I almost think it
might be C4 like the fact that he's
thinking as long as he is tells me that
he's considering some sort of very
committal option like Knight G6 or C4
and he's weighing the pros and cons
yeah he could he could play rookie too
and try to I wanted to point I thought
this was the idea rookie two Rook h8 I
actually go here with Tempo Donya ah and
if you and if you move the Knight maybe
I can put a pony on G6 you check me I
don't care and I pop in and I got mate
and bake all right it didn't happen but
I think that was rookie two was also
interesting you were right there C4 C4
C4 yeah because
logically why is he taking a minute well
because he understands that C4 is a very
committal move because it potentially
changes the structure I think Wesley
yeah keeps the tension rookie h8 Rook H1
so Magnus this is what he was thinking
about he self pins his knight uh but he
is potentially threatening tactics with
like Knight G6 at the right moment yeah
this is gonna get very tactical oh my
gosh something definitely exist here
this looks so crazy Rook H2 what is it I
think just Rook H2 start by bringing the
Rook onto a square such that you can
either double on the e-file or in an
emergency drop the Knight back to F3 and
make the water landing
okay
I like that wow good call the prophet
lives we're gonna get that emote of
Johnny on chess.com soon here Rook H2
you were right sir
I love this threat I keep waiting for
tactics where I take E7 and check and by
the way when you take Donya I take on h8
instead or something I don't know I'm
just having fun right now with a
coloring book on the board
man Wesley kept um the G6 square is
hurting him yeah this is this is a real
problem
I don't know what to do
oh okay seven okay
but okay uh the vegetarian
Wesley that's why he played Rook H7
brilliant defensive idea Magnus may have
rushed it I don't think Magnus saw that
we're looking at oh facial expression
for Magnus where he goes wait a second I
didn't see that coming
um
should have kept the tension it it if on
person by the way you're just taking it
everything's safe that's the key take
and take back you gotta drop your knight
back to F3 Magnus down to nine seconds
and maybe it's Wesley's turn to turn one
of these games around stick that night
on D5 stabilize in the center and look
at that Bishop on E7 Danny I almost
called you Wesley how it holds the two
infiltration squares e688 it's a team
effort The Rook on H7 holds the seventh
Rank and he's safe as houses here
you can call me Wesley just don't call
me Shirley right now Wesley so maybe he
turns around don't let that Knight land
on F4 okay yeah Magnus trades it off
before it goes to the mating net Square
have you ever been in a Turkish prison
what's her Vector Victor over over
rookie seven and this game might be over
pretty quickly because I think we're
gonna be a draw nietzsa draw draw
um unless there's some weird blunder
where the bishop Gets behind the pawn
chain and we've got light Square
problems but
that normally doesn't happen
yep
uh you might get your Bishop track speed
exactly what you're doing I mean this
this king is gonna oh wait the bishop
has E4 I'm sorry there was never an idea
to trap it white can play B5 and it
you're advised not to put the pawns on
attackable squares but because they're
all defended it doesn't matter it's a
moot point right okay A5
and we're gonna get some sort of a
repetition momentarily
and Wesley's plan with house money here
in terms of the match strategy because
if you look again the five minute
portion is over so it's not like trying
to win in a position where he can't
really is wasting any other uh
opportunities as far as the overall meta
strategy here remember everybody we're
gonna have 60 Minutes of three minute
and then 30 minutes of bullet and Wesley
so accepts the draw but he tried his
best didn't really lose any other time
on the overall match clock and what is
our match score on that note it is a
four game lead for Magnus Carlson Dania
narodisky your thoughts Danny wrench I
think the second half of the five-minute
portion was encouraging for Wesley he
did not cut into that deficit it's still
at four but the deficit did not grow to
six or seven which it absolutely can
when Magnus is feeling it Wesley scored
his first win of the match he was in
control of a lot of these latest few
games Danny but in the three-minute
portion he's gonna actually have to
capitalize on these somewhat or clearly
better positions
yeah but you know you have to crawl
before you can walk and so I just want
to build on that point I do think he's
carrying a little bit of confidence a
little bit of momentum here into the
three minute portion because as you said
he was controlling those last few games
maybe one got away from him he did get
his his first Victory as well so you got
to be happy if you are Wesley so and you
got to be happy if you are a fan out
there who's using coinbase for all of
your crypto needs that's what I mean
because coinbase is as fast and as smart
as the speech Chess Championship and if
you've been doing anything else with
your desires in the web 3 crypto World
here you've been messing up it's time to
update your system go to coinbase.com
update the system and use them for all
of your needs we love coinbase around
here we appreciate their support and uh
real quick Donya I want to ask you if
we're right that some momentum is
building in Wesley so's Corner what can
we expect from him in 3-1 and how would
you come out of the gates trying to
strike
well first of all I would keep a very
close eye on the clock that's where
Wesley struggled against Ali Reza he
started getting into time pressure and
that time pressure turns into bad
results you can't afford to go down to
five seconds in a middle game against
Carlson so quick play try to control the
game out of the opening and try to make
sure that the first 15 minutes of the
three minute portion go your way set the
tone with an early victory yeah and keep
that confidence up
I love that especially because setting
the tone means more than just getting a
game or two it means keeping up with the
pace because remember the SEC you have
two enemies your opponent and that clock
that's counting down above your head 60
Minutes will Wesley so have enough time
to at least make this thing close before
we head into the bullet we're gonna find
out don't go anywhere fans it's the
three minute portion in the speed Chess
Championship presented by toy base and
we will be right back
[Music]
thank you
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
[Music]
focusing on
we fell in love with playing
chess has been around for more than 1
000 years but that doesn't mean that we
can't modernize it Financial systems
have been around for even longer sounds
like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games hey
we're trying to have a lesson here you
need to get out of here recently more
kids have been playing chess than ever
in school but sadly we've learned that
they may not always be playing chess at
the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your
studies seriously and cooperating with
your fellow students and teachers
over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
all right that was awesome everybody
great job look what I did Danny did you
spell that yeah
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
oh my goodness
goodbye one Bang Bang
is a mate threat oh he's lost he's
positioned but does he have enough time
oh my gosh Magnus has to show off the
mouse speed right now this could be over
if Hikaru can bleed another minute off
the batch clock here we go oh oh oh no
he doesn't have enough time it's over
Magnus gives a little bit clap forehead
car Nakamura
[Music]
and that highlight reel was Magnus Carl
since 2022 SCC run there he is sitting
waiting to continue his current
semi-final matchup in the 2023 speed
Chess Championship brought to you by
coinbase and Dania first of all that was
an awesome highlight reel that was so
much fun last year covering those games
how how amp for you to see all those
brilliant moves by Magnus dude honestly
the magnusi Caro final was one of the
best commentating experiences of my life
and a lot of it is due to the incredible
chat engagement but also due to the high
level of Chess that was demonstrated not
just in his match against Hikaru but as
we see in this graphic Danny in his
runner-up matches where he just smashed
through the opposition his match against
Fabby we took that call that was insane
it was insane that moment rookie four I
remember how he kind of corralled the
king in that meeting that in real time
it's fun to go down memory lane but yeah
look it didn't end the way Magnus wanted
that's the thing though right he lost to
Hikaru and is he on path to making the
finals again
losing to hikara again or riding the
ship in regards to how he views things
we're gonna find out right right now he
still has Wesley so to take care of he's
taking off his hoodie looks like he's
got another golf polo on we know that
Magnus has been golfing these days
enjoying that game Wesley sitting up he
knows he's got to figure something out
here
wake up Susie and Wesley taking a sip of
hopefully caffeinated tea that looked
real I like tea in uh in in a glass uh
there's something very like Soviet about
that but Wesley needs to uh show some
Soviet mental fortitude and he needs to
go into Russian Schoolboy mode because
he's got a four-point deficit to make up
and 60 Minutes of three plus one
is what we have now in a Bishop's
opening something new very nice
yeah Bishop's opening is not one you see
every day but it's a fun move order
especially for Bliss it just means you
developed the bishop to C4 on move two
for those who don't speak opening
encyclopedia uh but we've we've now
transposed into some sort of Vienna game
with the Knight coming to C3 the Vienna
is defined as where you put the Knight
on C3 before the king side night again
for those who don't speak opening
encyclopedia
um but now guess what in the end it
doesn't matter because we've completely
transposed to a four nights down here
guys like that that's the thing about
the Bishops opening it's it's like
Newark airport or or you know Frankfurt
airport as I like to say by stream it's
like how often do you go there in order
to remain in Frankfurt or Newark rarely
right you fly off to some other
destination so there are these
transpositional openings and it's always
cool to see how it transposes from one
opening to another and then finally it
kind of settles in on a traditional four
nights symmetrical position as Wesley
goes for the bishop pair a typical move
there Knight A4 and I I like this for
white I think wise position is pleasant
but Magnus clearly knows what he's doing
and I'm going to call that out because
you said Wesley needed to get up on the
clock and set the tone right now he's
down on the clock Magnus seems to know
what he's doing of course it's very
early it's literally you know 45 seconds
into game one so we're not going to
overthink it but Wesley played an
interesting move order but he needs to
show it needs to prove and get an
advantage as we get to the middle game
and we're probably going to see Magnus
deploying his LightScribe Bishop to E6
and posing Wesley with another decision
okay rookie eight to start
um and when will Wesley take on B6
that's a big question I would
procrastinate too long
but the player is kind of just making
these standard italian-esque moves and
there's our answer Bishop B5 by Wesley
he does it repairing he doesn't
frequency
gonna take on C6 and double the pawns
the old-fashioned way if you play A6
I'll take here and double the pawns that
way probably before saving the bishop I
would imagine although maybe not
um okay maybe no maybe you'll actually
just take here and not take the bit
donda you're the Grand Master what
should we do here it's like you can get
the burger with the mayonnaise and
without the lettuce or with the lettuce
it's like you're making your own little
Chipotle Bowl on the queen side okay the
other side he wants the Glock yeah yeah
he wants the guac give me the guac hey
we got a guac over here in order for two
um meaning he traded both sets of miners
there then he plays D4 to change the
structure and and now
uh now I I kind of like the position
with D6 being weak but at some point
black is going to play D5 anyway and
it's possible to play it now D5 E5 is
Wesley's intended a response and then
the Knight could drop back to H7 very
underrated Square
um or move forward to H5 in order to
clamp down on the dark squares Magnus
pushes a different Pawn I think he wants
to open up a little window for his
Bishop on C6 and he is still preparing
to push D5 but Wesley could beat him to
the punch and stick his seat Pawn on C4
which is why Magnus just put his Bishop
on E6
yeah instead of C6
is this yes yes
you know Robert is there another
position
yeah
you know Robert Hooper was one of the
most crafty gentlemen I've ever met yeah
you know exactly he knew how to put the
binder pieces on all the right squares
and he always seemed to have the tactics
go his way and then you know just when
the game reached its critical point he
would push his glasses up in in that
fake German accent of his he would say
this is a very good Bishop
[Laughter]
and Morgantown population Wesley's work
on A1
nothing like being ripped out of an
amazing Yasser sarawan impersonation
experience to someone blundering I was
like in a trance and then before you
know it I got a blunder on the board
um
Knight takes C6 Queen takes day one
Danny and if you pick up the Knight on
D5
Magnus picks up the night on E6 and then
he can trade Queens by lifting his Queen
back to D4 this is just lost right off
the bat
oh Knight F4
that is not something that Robert hubner
would have been happy about you no
exactly would resign here and Wesley
might as well
yeah it is a fork the piece on F4 is
double attacked The Rook on A1 has a
single attacker but nothing you can do
about it
and that is what happens when you put
your pieces on loose squares in the open
board Wesley scratching his head
frustrated with his play right now as we
can understand that is unfortunate
oh man and uh yeah I said it at the
start Nanny I mean the of all the things
of all the ways that you can lose to
Magnus as Wesley resigns that that said
he just loses the exchange not a
premature resignation the way to lose
fastest is these one move blenders
Magnus has a 99 success rate at finding
easy tactics and you can't hand this
these things to him on a golden platter
not the way that Wesley wanted to start
the three-minute portion they lost the
white pieces and an immediate adjustment
with black as he throws all caution to
the wind and plays a dwarf
right but note that Magnus goes right in
for some of the most aggressive rookie
one with G4 ideas in the in the night
off that's sometimes called the perenni
attack and this in this world the
chess.com encyclopedia is saying the
freak attack
one is called you like that I prefer
lines named after people
um and but I've heard it perennially
referred to as the freak attack as well
and the reason the big reason that they
got popular is a chessable course on the
night off by Gregor gayevsky who was I
believe a second divisionande and Rook
G1 was pulled out of the dead because it
was popular it flared up in popularity
in the 90s with Vasily avantra then the
popularity died down and then new ideas
were found by guyevsky but the way
Magnus is playing this is kind of weird
he's mixing two different systems
remember he played that Bishop E2 Bishop
G5 line but he's kind of transitioning
the game into those types of svechnikavi
the structure
it's awfully special kavi and even this
idea of relocating the bishop to this
diagonal but I like it even more for so
than the normal svenge into coffee
because there's no Castle in kingside
here when you move your Rook we're gonna
make sure that the king stays in the
center Magnus is like all right no
problem bro
wow what a what a freaky looking
position here in the freak attack you
know
the pawn on H5 is just a freak
occurrence isn't it
it is
and it was freaky when Gregor gayevsky
also brought back saggy pants from the
90s he brought back rookie one and he
brought back saggy pants and people like
we're doing this again we've got set and
no no apparently not girl that was a
freakishly accurate description
Bishop to E6 is played
the thing about Black's position that's
that is to be preferred is that there
are still more options with the King you
can actually go both ways depending on
what happens but white is up in
development don't be surprised if okay
the Knight goes immediately to D5
you're threatening to win zibicha yeah
something just explore but usually it's
sacrificed in this position I would
Castle I would castle kingside and
that's I think for newer players total
anathema because you're taught never to
Castle if you have you know a Pawn on H5
the thing is blackened push G6 which is
often what happens in this fashion I
think site is actually a much safer
place to be than the center is it
perfect is it you know a villa in Malibu
no but staying in the center has its own
dangers
yeah I hear you but Wesley is open to
those dangers he says I laugh in the
face of danger Here Comes Harry
here goes Harry
he wants counter play
Harry the H Pawn advances forward and
the benefit of keeping your king in the
center is that your Rook on h8 could
ultimately infiltrate via H2
what is Magnus gonna do in response
Bishop whoa
Kyle the king king D2 he Castles by hand
and he already has the plan because C2
is available even if you threw in a
check for good measure I thought he
wasn't going to Castle Queen side
someone's about to walk up to this board
Dania in a few seconds right they just
got done taking out their garbage for
their mom on Twitch he's like Mom can I
go watch the SEC now yeah honey you dig
a garbage and they're going to be like
Madness Castle Queens
hey it was not a bad southern accent man
I didn't know you lived in South
Carolina King C1 and just sip on your
ice tea because my king is safest houses
higher
that is you know of all your accents
we've been meaning to talk to you about
this this one is not your best I'm just
I want to be honest we've got about 30
000 people watching here between
teaching YouTube and hey it's not your
best policy I'll work on it it's okay
I'll work on it it's okay Charlotte will
help all right no but seriously Magnus
heads up play finds a way to confuse the
kid at home with his mom on Twitch
everyone looks at this position says
that white castled long and look at the
advantage White's up now you're gonna
put the King on B1 D6 is going to be
weak
and guess what Danny Wesley will pay the
price for pushing his age Pawn Magnus
can actually say Hey you want the open
King side I'll give you an open King
side there we go g takes H4 was possible
F4 same type of idea trying to open up
the G file for that Rook on G1
I knew he was going to play a four I saw
it coming but you're right GTX H4 was
almost as spicy this is getting crazy
he's also up 20 seconds on the clock
um and and I think Wesley either Miss
King D2 or clearly underestimated
because it really was jokes aside a
really crucial idea because all these
things you're doing as white right now
don't work if your king is on E1
everybody Magnus got the king to safety
oh wait what oh there was H takes G3
there which was a very hard move to spot
leaving The Rook on seat on pre
and then picking up the H2 Pawn with
Tempo that was an exchange sack which
would have seized the initiative now
Magnus needs to get that Bishop out of
there and he does he does and now he's
back in the driver's seat
that's a heads up play Wesley missed a
huge opportunity to get two pawns and
interest for the exchange
from B3 maybe to E4 putting more
pressure in the center this is a Magnus
type of position I think yeah there we
go
he's going for it relocating the pony
both C4 and E4 are open for business
depending
ooh speaking of business Wesley means
business on the king side finally
reaping the benefits of opening the age
file and now striking at the other side
Bishop takes C3 is something before
Bishop takes E3 money yeah possible yeah
very much so let's get fancy here he
needs to take this game it's a Time
scramble it's a 50 50 position can
Wesley keep his nerves here
he plays king of fate
but he misses a chance from Knight E4
once that Bishop goes all of your
attacking chances on the queen side go
with it that's not good for Wesley
exactly and the position becomes a lot
more clearly defined and easier to play
Magnus doesn't have to rush with Knight
takes F6 but he does he doesn't want to
play with fire and his Bishop is
obviously superior to the Knight on G6
which of course as we've been pointing
out is restricted by that pawn on F4 so
the position is not terrible for Wesley
but it's hard to navigate this in a time
pressure situation your king is also
very weak on f8 yeah
okay but Magnus trades away enough
pieces that now black not facing nearly
as much pressure with the minor pieces
gone the major piece in game can be held
there's even actually one coming that's
the point that's what Magnus missed he
should have put his Queen on H2 if he
had put his Queen on H2 he would have
had Rook H1 in that position now Wesley
can trade Rooks and make the draw yeah
I think I think Wesley will hold this
they're both under five seconds though
so again weird things do happen when
you're under time pressure let's not uh
okay look at Wesley he goes B5 he wins
upon ending oh my God I lost I lost my
headphones oh my God hold on I'll hear
you in a second
ah dude you're hilarious but look at
Wesley he's advancing his King to G4
he's gonna flag he's giving up his Pawn
Magnus his King magnus's King Danny went
from the King side to the queen side to
the center to Black side of the board
and Magnus wins oh man oh my gosh oh my
gosh Lynn oh my God I'm a God that was
so crazy
wow
that that was a backbreaker it was funny
Donna what B5 was first first played in
the eval bar which reveals all went
crazy I'm like why and then greedy for
check and like oh my God you always have
to anticipate the transition from the
current endgame to the more simplified
one fans and I know I'm saying things
that Wesley so obviously knows but it is
instructive because even Grand masters
of this level push pawns carelessly went
under time pressure Donya and one of the
first rules you learn is don't just
evaluate whether your pieces are working
now but always anticipate the evolution
of the position and that was an example
drawn Queen upon ending Donya lost King
and pawn ending is what happened there
well said and the reason it was lost is
as you said that move B5 completely
unnecessary uh push of the pawn Wesley
was trying to threaten Checkmate
forgetting that he's actually creating a
weakness that's eminently accessible by
the white king Magnus anticipated it and
this is why he's the best endgame player
of all time he's also winning the next
game this is the wheels are coming off
completely look at his last move Danny
Knight before look at the bishop on B5
live it's about to be massacred by the
black pawns with C6 and D5 the wheels
the wheels are off here and this could
get out of control it's on the cusp of
getting out of control I think a
five-point lead or it's a six point lead
oh no yeah it's already a six-point lead
and we didn't even have proper time to
grieve the last loss before we look at
the current position and we've got we've
got problems as you said Knight B4 not
only threatens some Forks but we got
more forking problems C6 A6 B5 D5 you
name it that Bishop is running out of
squares I think this game might be over
before I begin we're 10 moves in and
Wesley has the white pieces I don't like
his choice of the NIMS of which Larson I
think he never got the positions he
wanted to get but he seems to be
repeating it trying to get the game out
of theory but he succeeded he's also
gotten himself into a hole six point
hole and possibly a seven point hole as
he struggles to find some way to keep
the game going I think he has to play
Knight B1 and A3 that might be the only
move to Stave off defeat
Knight B1
yeah that's a a tough move to play but
he's got to do it he's got no other
moves
[Music]
back up the night you meet C6 or A6 with
A3 and we get a big old trade
if white can find those moves maybe it's
not over but he's down two minutes on
the clock unfortunately Magnus takes
that confident sip of water as the
theory goes you only drink water when
you're confident which is why I'm
constantly trying to drink water on
screen to pretend that I'm confident hey
I'm holding up both of my beverages at
the same time both of the glasses are
empty but let's not talk about that
let's talk about Wesley's clock instead
which is about to dwindle down to zero
it's unfortunate
yeah yeah this this has the these two
players have the potential to have some
of the closest matches and just some of
the highest quality games oh and
Magnus is bringing the pain he takes E3
it's brilliant the first brilliant move
on the board it's gonna be followed by
D5
D5 and we live and why did he do that
because he's winning the bishop back but
he's softening up White's pawns White's
position is now riddled it's riddled
with holes the pawn on E3 is isolated
Wesley's not developed he had to
undevelop in order to save the minor
piece now Magnus has the long-term
pressure on the d-pawn and the e-pawn a
move like C5 here is what the doctor
ordered to fix White's Pawns in the end
game is just misery for white and 12
seconds on top of that
great movie Misery
um
by Maroon 5. you said 12 seconds 12
Angry Men ocean 12 not so hot not so hot
of a sequel 12 Monkeys
yeah now you're in territory unfamiliar
to me
sound effect dhanya has entered the room
um
chances may be
this idea
yeah
Uncle Sasha what do you think about that
maybe some sort of before 95 rockefan
and I have some chances
that is that is a great Wesley Zone
version everyone knows it it's a great
one um your old Uncle Sasha is very
proud
um but I no I've just I'm sitting here
thinking like how does this turn around
if you're crawling in Wesley's mind
it's tough
I mean you just got to embrace the suck
I mean whatever cliche that whatever
filler phrase you want to tell yourself
if you're Wesley you got to tell
yourself that phrase and at the end of
the day I mean right now I wouldn't even
focus on the comeback I wouldn't focus
on the concept of tying the match I
always say that when you're facing a
deficit this big your only chance is to
break it up into bite-sized pieces right
now keep the deficit to six to seven and
try to reduce it to something like four
going into the bullet because in the
bullet you've got the biggest chance of
any time control to actually develop a
streak because in bullet you can get
tilted even Magnus can get tilted in the
bullet and he has in the past so keep
this to within relative Striking
Distance that's your only goal right now
if you're Wesley and he's not succeeding
in that either he's losing game after
game can he hold this one I don't think
so
gets forked on F2 that's a forking way
to lose and ah
94 rookie 4 he wants and then Knight C7
but oh it is but little relief 94 rookie
four oh you can oh you could have taken
on D5 Intermezzo that uh Magnus missed
there I think that might have actually
been better I'm just banking on his epon
he might want to go Rook D1 or something
crazy to throw Wesleyan for a loop Rook
D1 and E3 great move in time pressure
I'm not sure it wins but yeah Rook D1
and E3 this position is spicy here only
three seconds for Wesley but Magnus
Maybe
joining him in the time scramble here
he's calculating Rook T1 he goes for it
wow
he's gonna do it nice
goes all in for this idea Bishop F7 and
Wesley could guard his Rook by dropping
his King back to B2 and suddenly the
position sharpens up again King B2 he's
gotta find it no time on the clock takes
C4 that's the problem
but if okay seven seconds
ah time
Wesley's frustrated he actually he was I
think he kind of had a bit of a smile
because he was happy with how he played
it but then it kind of it didn't matter
because the clock got away from him
um
living on the increment will do that to
you but let's move Carlson extends his
lead let's Bureau that final position
was virtually indefensible even if he
had made a move it was only a matter of
time
before he would have lost
hey
sometimes sometimes
sometimes I was telling you a way to
turn sometimes into the time that we
inserted unnecessary puns about time
into a show like just now but okay are
we gonna get an interesting interesting
most exciting chess game of all time we
commentate on
Magnus Magnus has played Bishop before
again there's a chance to repeat moves
oh no it didn't happen never mind didn't
happen what on Earth are we getting what
kind of a London is do they realize that
they have other pieces Wesley Carlson
you have other pieces other than the
dark side Bishop Wesley other than your
G8 Knight F6 don't play F6 cram Nick
would what yeah
sorry protest and then and then his
opponent would play resign
what would he play
you know what's a funny line you know
what's the funny line F6 F6 Bishop takes
C7 and after Queen takes C7 black wins
because you've got the d8 square for
your case that is funny actually
all right well uh Wesley is
unfortunately feeling a little bit on
tilt for those wondering why you would
play Knight F6 Knight H5 you know a
little bit of chill but at the same time
you know it's a dynamic position at the
very least there are still multiple
results possible
the best way to mount a comeback losing
this one at this point though I think
Wesley is trying to just look to change
the pace right I don't know you got to
do something to throw things off but
he's changing the pace from at least
maintaining the deficit to basically
dropping games out of the opening and
this is not the way you can't play like
this against Magnus because when you
play this type of unconventional chess
far from getting thrown off Danny Magnus
Embraces and he says thank you very much
for a winning position out of the
opening we're going to see E4 right
abort boarding and I were talking about
yes about this yesterday one of the many
things that makes Magnus such an
incredible Blitz player is that he it's
like he drives a manual and he can shift
gears at a moment's notice from grinding
out a long end game to bang bang taking
on passant opening up the center and
sacrificing pieces
yep
I agree as we always say that's he
doesn't have a lot of weaknesses he's
pretty good at winning all types of
positions to beat Magnus Carlson you
have to play the best moves and you have
to play them fast and I don't know what
else to say right it's it's a tough
world going up against the highest rated
player in history
and you said also early in the match
that if he did get a lead he wasn't
going to let up he's often ruthless and
uh
it is it is a funny thing that you don't
talk a lot about we have a moment to do
so because there's a big lead here Dania
that part of magnus's greatness is I
think he really does appreciate that
when he wins a match against someone
Donya it's more than just that match if
he dominates and really leaves a mark
psychologically you know how much harder
it is for people to beat him in the
future
and I don't think I I don't think he
doesn't think about that I think Magnus
you know appreciates the opportunity to
leave a mark if you will
I completely agree I think we can think
of him as a scientist you know it's not
he wants to be perfect right for him the
the game and the match is surgery and he
wants to perfect his craft he knows that
yeah he can probably take his foot off
the gas pedal and realistically he's
probably going to win the match but
that's not the Magnus uh that's not how
he's become Magnus Carlson in the first
place he's become Magnus Carlson by
holding himself to a ruthlessly high
standard regardless of the situation in
the match or in the tournament that he's
played how many times Danny has he
basically bagged a tournament after the
first half and rather than coasting with
a bunch of draws he actually extends his
lead and he plays the second half of the
tournament like he's in must-win
situations Knight A7 Knight C6 by the
way that is I was just about to say
Knight A7 Knight C6 is freaking oh he
does it oh my God
I salute him
the queen comes to A5 we're checkmating
each other only one person is really
doing the meeting but
age six fell Danny and that's the reason
that Wesley is losing it's that age six
Knight which Magnus picks up at the end
look at the whole board awareness of
that of that sequence yeah
yeah
okay well
welcome to the speeches Championship
presented by coinbase welcome to Magnus
Carlson welcome to the Magnus Carlson
revenge tour he wants to win this year's
event making up for his epic it was epic
but it was a finals defeat to Hikaru
Nakamura and uh and yeah it it doesn't
look like he will be denied today again
we still have another hour of Chess
total on the game clock 30 minutes of
three minutes above Magnus 30 minutes of
bullet
and we're gonna have a lot of fun in the
meantime we're gonna learn some things
we're going to make some really awkward
jokes Don just gonna slip in and out of
accents we're gonna have some puns so
don't go anywhere but uh this is the
Magnus Carlsen world and I am a Magnus
Carlson girl or boy
that same girl it is his it is his world
right now oh my lands and not to bring
up you know to dig up old skeletons
Danny but remember that Carlson Carolina
match that we mentioned at the beginning
of the second 22-4 was the final score
and if somebody hasn't seen that match
you can wonder what what is the anatomy
of a speaking of skeletons what is the
anatomy of a 22-4 match how does that
even happen over the course of three
hours well I think now you're beginning
to see how it happens right he just at
some point he just starts to win one
game after the other and as big as a 16
point lead sounds it's actually not that
big when Magnus is in machine mode as he
is right now and when his opponent is as
debilitated uh and as demoralized as
Wesley so is and can you blame him it's
like no matter what you do you're gonna
lose that's the feeling you start
getting and that's when the Tilt really
sets in
yep
and it's funny because I I mean you and
I commented on that match last year
where Magnus beat Fabiano
and we saw some highlights of it before
the break if you're just getting here
where have you been but I remember now
as you as you kind of jog uh that
conversation back into my head here
Donya that we were also talking about
magnus's ruthlessness in that match and
that he was leaving a mark in Fabiano's
brain to make sure that if they're ever
in the SEC again remember what happened
last time remember right he was going uh
full John Malkovich here he's gone full
Teddy KGB right he's reminding him what
happened the last time they played and
and he wants to win with a huge Victory
because because I think he knows that it
matters and and psychological factors
are very real at the top levels of chess
if you don't believe you can beat
someone Donya at the game of chess you
probably can't
magnus's Improvement in in the sphere of
online chess is actually pretty amazing
and I know it's crazy to say magnus's
Improvement in one sense because how
much can this guy improve he's already
this good but if you look at Magnus
during the covet area it's 20 20 21 he
was a lot less consistent a b he was
less fast he's almost always leading on
the clock if he's playing anybody except
yukara Nakamura and C he's almost more
confident within the context of bullet
and Blitz just all of those bullet
brawls all of the title Tuesdays Danny
all of the sccrcc cgc matches all of
that has given Magnus the additional
experience he needs to extend his total
dominance to the sphere of online chess
and it's an amazing amazing opportunity
for us it's a privilege honestly to
watch Magnus Carlson shifting his Focus
from Over the board chest which he will
continue to play to online chess at
exactly the right time
yeah
and I agree with Chad let's go Wesley
come on Wesley let's go all of that said
let's go openly rooting for Wesley so to
knock knock a few games his Direction
the improbable only happens if that
happens and as you said You Gotta Have
Whatever cliche is necessary in your
head one game at a time you know one
position at a time one move at a time
right you gotta just start with one
thing at a time it's like those uh post
game basketball interviews which are
just like platitude after platitude but
you can't blame the player because he's
like totally out of breath all right
which is down the stretch you know on
the defensive end and Coach coach just
put me in and just had to hit a couple
big shots and you know just up and down
floor and and uh defensive effort and
resilience to repeat all those words to
himself and then you forgot to say it
and uh you know it is what it is it is
what it is and it is 100 100 out there
like very good
the uh
all right A3 is played by Wesley that
actually is a a good move here you're
you're taking care of the lack of
development you have
um Magnus will probably play A5 and say
no he doesn't he goes B3 he wants the B2
Pawn a little bit of uh
kicks and Giggles here I was about to
say Wesley has more time than he started
with and then I realized we're not
playing the bullet yet we're not playing
bullet no no although he is up on the
clock so again a single Victory starts
right now to answer the question from
the chatter earlier no just believing
you can beat Magnus does not get the job
done but you do have to start with the
belief if you're a top level player and
you oh yeah you're nice and then Bishop
D3 and rookie one is coming The Rook is
trapped and Wesley loses another one
problem
your old Uncle Sasha has this memory one
time in Siberia when it got away from me
and just like that I was riding a bear
in a siberian prison okay very nice back
to the show Wesley now has been informed
it's time to take our halftime break
Magnus doesn't look too thrilled with
his inability to get his hand completely
down his shirt he's going to continue to
work on that at the break
and in the meantime
we're going to remind you all of where
we sit on the scoreboard
uh well
oh my gosh
where do we sit on the scoreboard Danny
remind us how big of a lead is it it's a
nine point lead
it's in a game lead Aid game lead I
apologize I'm jumping the gun here ten
and a half two and a half is our score
but the three minute portion Danny we're
in make adoption territory
yep no it's a nine point lead five zero
it okay it just hadn't been updated yet
there you go it is a nine point lead you
are right I don't know whether we're in
the 10 game territory yet for those who
don't speak online chess fluently the
term adoption was coined when you win 10
games against someone that is all it
means
um and right now Magnus Carlson
might be on route to doing just that
with one of the greatest Blitz players
in the history of the game so Dania uh
I'm gonna just leave you with the floor
you want to comment on on how Wesley
does psychologically keep this together
what you do when you're facing Magnus
here and or talk about the greatness of
Mr Carlson you have the floor well we've
rehashed and and and rehashed the
greatness of Mr Carlson and he cannot be
rehashed enough you know it's one of
those things that you need to you need
to keep talking about it because newer
and newer aspects and elements of Magnus
Carlson's greatness keep coming onto the
surface and for Wesley so uh I think
there's a lot of Del Rey songs
Summertime Sadness I think that's what
Wesley is experiencing right now he's
demoralized you feel for him but he's
got to keep fighting part of the prize
fund is determined by the points that
you score Danny and this is what chess
professionals do even when you're down
by 50 points and your opposing team is
hitting three-pointer after
three-pointer you need to keep your legs
churning and you need to keep fighting
and that's what Wesley is going to do
because because we know Wesley foreign
he is going to keep doing that there is
enough cash to justify I think doing a 7
500 up for just pure win percentage
every game and uh as the prizes remain
up for grabs let me remind everyone
viewing that it is September so it's
still up for grabs for you to hit that
subscribe button and save up to 30
percent real quick real quick reminder
too that if you are a subscriber to the
twitch Channel it means no ads on
chess.com whether you're a premium
member on chess.com or not you may not
have known that all you have to do is
subscribe to our Twitch in fact throw us
your Prime because it's easy it takes
you a couple clicks connect your account
at chess.com and you will have an ad
free experience over there and again
your subs really do help if you didn't
know it you're missing content at every
break we play funny videos and have a
fun time so subscribe and you don't have
to see commercials you get to hear more
of Dania and see more funny videos and
Mr neraditski I think I think uh we're
gonna take a quick break when we return
it's the back half of the three minute
portion as we head toward the bullet
thank you to all of our subs we will be
right back with more SCC action in just
a few
foreign
[Music]
why did you on passant bro I swear to
god Amazon should be enforced all my
friends watching and this day is taking
forever play faster if I can move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb I should
be able to flag him no matter how many
times I repeat moves 1400 years and it's
the same game every time you
know what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it still
mate is now a win for the player who
gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen trout pawns can
move backwards why is that a never not
been a rule pawns come backwards now
every piece should be allowed to on
passant what that's not even possible
how ship it dunzo update enter Wiseman
ending there's just two kings on the
board what is this purgatory story this
is so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chess why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
wait what Checkmate do I have to get to
move from now on C4 actually explodes
it's our week no more
on the first move update take care
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alert you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
es from over 35 lessons created for all
skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
by coinbase it continues here with
Wesley so doing everything he can to
mount a comeback versus Magnus Carlson
who has been on form today and that is
the most PG way I can say
not Magnus Carlton has been playing it's
been it has been rated R it's not legal
in half the states what uh what's been
going on here it's been violent
aggressive chess for Magnus Carlson he's
up by nine games
Ki is with me
we've been calling the action that's the
scoreboard as we head into
the back half of the three minute and
games are underway don't you they are
underway it's a nine point deficit you
don't want this entering double-digit
territory because then hey you'll be in
pretty good company you'll be in nepo's
company uh and you'll be in the company
of everybody that Magnus has destroyed
over the last few years in the SEC and
that list is pretty wide for Wesley okay
29 minutes Danny you need to get this
down to I think at a minimum six points
to have even an iota of a chance to come
back in the bullet
agreed and I think at this point it's
it's almost irrelevant as to whether the
uh the comeback happens but just win one
game right just win the next game
and uh and see where that takes you I
think is the mindset that we're looking
for and um we have a a botvinic English
structure for black very solid Center
White employing a double fee in Keto
kind of system here lots of flexibility
here as I hurl my headphone wire back
I like this uh for both this is an
interesting position black putting
together what I refer to as the bot
Linux setup that's how it was taught to
me when you have these pawns on C5 D6
and E5 and then you have the fee
encounted Bishop that's how it's
characterized of course the drawback is
that you are weakening the D5 score but
that doesn't tell the whole story black
structure is very solid it's very
Compact and you do have the eventual
possibility of orchestrating Danny's
some King side play Maybe with an
eventual push of the F Pawn First you
trade the Bishops which definitely is in
Black's favor as well
yeah no you said it well I was also
taught that it was the bod thinning
English just FYI in case you're like was
I given a name that no one else used I'm
pretty sure it was the same name so
that's good we're in the we're in the
same camp there
um but uh yeah here's here's white
getting some Queen side play with B4 and
it's funny because you have to be
careful if the bot finish structure does
get undermined some things can change
quickly and if this Knight stays put
could become a real thorn even if it
turns into a protected pass Pawn great
point so quick quick interjection Danny
guess at what age Mikael batmanic uh
learned the rules of chess
if I had to guess it was like three or
something
it was double digits it was 12.
wow I read in his autobiography 12. can
you believe that I mean that's obviously
impossible anymore but uh back in Bob
the next time he was born in 1911
learned the rules of the game in 1923 or
so and just a couple of years later was
defeating Jose Capa Blanca in super
tournaments not a bad progression
that's a pretty impressive impressive
trajectory there that's a pretty awesome
path there but Finnick the father of the
the botvinic Soviet chess school and a
legend uh you look at you look at Navy
world champions in history if you ever
try to test yourself that you know sort
of the timeline of world champions when
you get into the bonfinic area it can
challenge you a little bit if you really
are trying to name everyone in
sequential order that it gets uh it gets
pretty rough because he both won and
then lost the world championship
multiple times
at absolutely it's it's like when you
try to name the presidents and you get
into like Tyler poke Taylor and then
Tyler and Taylor and schmaler and Van
Buren that's that's when the presidents
get less memorable you gotta the
smithslavs and the talls and the
petrosians and they all kept uh you know
going back and forth like Hikaru and
Magnus in the SEC
yeah it was uh a while like a wild time
please see Danny
I was okay okay so I'm just you sir I
don't wear a hat anymore because it
rapidly increases my balding so I don't
wear hats anymore
um but okay I tip my hat to you sir we
have a weak deep Pond we have a B file
we're fighting for Wesley has reinforced
it with the a pawn but uh
overall not a ton to write home about if
I had to choose though I kind of like
white despite the Deep Pawn being weak I
really get worried about the C Pawn I
feel like the E5 Pawn is a Target also
the square and I kind of feel like if a
transition happens here a trade of these
minor pieces I kind of like the Knight
but what do you think
I I'm sure your instinct I like the
Knight on C4 which could become a knight
on D5 in fact you can play Knight B6
right here and that is a Magnus esque
kind of move again look at that x-ray
defense of the Rook on B1 to the B6
square but Magnus kind of deciding yep
Knight B6 there it is oh he goes for it
yeah Danny the thing is once the Knight
gets to D5 black can challenge that
Knight by dropping his own Knight to E7
although even that is hard to achieve
because there is a fork on C7 that you
have to be very careful about allowing
yeah
well he puts the queen on A7 which
allows 97 so very good heads of play but
note that Magnus
is not messing around playing Super
quickly with his night moves working on
him working on those Night Moves he's
got by the way as any piece besides the
Knight moved in the last 10 movies
well the a pawn is about to move up and
sees the B file even at the cost of the
D3 Pawn worthy price to pay
and Bishop A5 instead do it weird now he
plays it
well now this isn't hanging so
interesting
the a pawn is but if you take the a pawn
you allow the infiltration Danny of
White's Queen to B7 and the Bishop from
A5 can challenge the knight from d8 what
about that juicy little move yeah Bishop
d8 would be uh
a move you regret allowing so instead
Wesley plays Knight to C6
uh
you have this uh Sloan
uh cone digit Theory you have uh okay
very nice
um now okay wait bring the queen no the
Knight comes back to B6 he loves
maneuvering
and reinforcing now oh look at that
night you know how to say Outpost in
Russian uh I used to I've lost my so
many of them
what is it I think that term is an
obscure chest term in English well it's
foreign
Schoolboy lesson for the day chat I love
it I love it
okay Queen to C4 the queen is inching
forward Wesley so has not played like
the Soviet Schoolboy you said he needed
to be when the wheels started to come
off Magnus is pushing hard in every
position although this one's getting
weird
some time pressure ensuing for both
players
yep Queen E6 Queen E6 is begging to be
played especially now with the epon week
but Magnus adheres to his strategy he's
trying to get his King over to the queen
side uh delegating the task of stopping
the pawn to his King so that his Queen
and Knight are free to roam about the
cabin but yeah Queen E7 Wesley
blundering the a pawn there was no need
to give that away and he's uncomfortable
here the knight from D5 what a move
blocking the Queen's path oh
and it threatens the bishop it blocked
the queen from coming in
he's got made on h8 whoa did you see
that Queen B7 Queen C8 and now he's
gonna promote his Apon and Wesley has
not a single check another Victory and
look at the Knights defense of the king
there right that as you said was the key
to not having any checks we always say
the Knight is the best defender right
around the king and that was one of
those moments where the queen just felt
helpless she couldn't get enough counter
play
man I hate to say the word
and Russian that word is
you know it starts with an A and it ends
with an option yeah how many games has
he won
six I think because the final game of
the three minute portion uh five-minute
portion was drawn but six in a row
against Wesley so are you kidding me
fun fact the person who holds the record
for the most adoptions on chess.com is
Hikaru Nakamura with 524 total adoptions
of other human chess players
it's a lot of kids man
this includes child support 67. this
includes 67 double adoptions which
depending on the state you're in can be
really complicated in the court but 67
double adoptions and one adoption over
Yours Truly Daniel wrench
and speaking of the audience you know I
would have some adoption stats ready for
today that was that was Nifty you
brought that out at exactly the right
moment but the problem is that we talk
about it and and first of all none of
this is intended to make and I think
you'll co-sign me on this Danny we feel
for Wesley this is a very tough
situation to be in it's not like an open
tournament where you lose a couple games
and you drop down to face a weaker
opponent
um it's like you drop down to face
Magnus Carlson and then you lose and you
drop down to face Magnus Carlson and
then you face Magnus Carlson and this
Magnus Carlson becomes stronger and
stronger with every Victory so it's like
you know a big boss that just grows more
evil with every passing game but all
hats all hats off to Magnus this guy is
insane
yep no obviously and at this point we're
having fun Wesley knows Wesley has
Wesley is an amazing chess player with
an incredible career who has beaten
Magnus in some very big moments but
today is not his day and no one's gonna
hold that against him but it is
impressive when you see someone like
Carlson do what he's doing because
regardless of Wesley not being on form
it takes
super form Super Saiyan form right over
9000 to have the focus Donya to beat
Wesley so six times in a row you get
what I'm saying like it's it's next
level stuff and yeah I get what you're
saying you get what I'm saying because
it's super because if you listen to what
I'm saying it's super it might even be
over 9 000 words before I really drive
this Awkward Moment home hey as the old
saying goes Magnus Carlson is an
impressive chess player and he will
start to squeeze this position with
black I actually think Wesley was better
out of the gates but now that Magnus has
established uh this Knight on C5 and uh
fixed the queen Side Pawn structure to
his favor I think Wesley's best bet is
to prepare G4 put a rook on H1 and try
to smash through the king side with your
Pawns
yeah
well I've been saying it for years that
if you have an opportunity to pry open
your opponent's king
you do it find the lever open up the
files we're more infantry can enter
well Rook D1 Wesley playing on all sides
of the board and attacking D6 and trying
to meet Rook D7 I think with Bishop C6
and suddenly that pawn doesn't feel
quite as well protected as it did just a
couple of moves ago I think Magnus is
best advised just to jettison it
um and say you can take the pawn but
you're gonna have to allow the queen
trade and that's going to take the heat
off of the king side
yeah
he does he does choose to jettison the
pawn and end game is not the worst thing
for black because the Knight is super
well placed here it hits B3 the pawns on
dark swears are hard for the bishop to
gang up on so kind of as Don just said
get letting go of the pawn
even if White's doing okay black is
actually you know this position actually
probably still is a three result game in
many ways totally especially given what
we've seen in previous end games I mean
how many games just in this match Danny
uh have we seen that started off uh
seemingly as two result games we had
that Karo Khan game we had games in the
early part of the match and then
suddenly in the blink of an eye bang
Magnus is in charge he's playing for the
win and then bang you make one mistake
and the game is over
yep
and it's funny because again Wesley won
the pawn but Black's position has more
to improve I mean you you bring the king
out which he already started you're
gonna put the the king here maybe you
can trade Brooks and if everybody comes
off the D file uh the b3point hangs in
the end so so this is
this is tricky I guess that's the point
it's it's a puric victory for Wesley
because as a result of his excellent
play he's won the D6 one he's checked
the Box he's won the war but Magnus has
won the piece and uh not literally but
figuratively and he might win a piece if
that Rook on C6 doesn't get out of the
gates here draws the likeliest result
because neither side can make easy
progress but that's gonna milk more time
off the match clock and Wesley you can
just sense the frustration uh all the
way across the across the the ocean
well he plays King E7 will he try to
trap that Rook or trade that Rook
because you can kind of sit tight but I
don't know that there's really more ways
to get out there you lack squares like
A6
because of the bishop so I don't know
exactly how you really get at this rook
and at some point you might just want to
simplify the position
or just Shuffle right little Shuffle
putt
do you think Magnus is actively thinking
about adoption is he going to go for the
win here and burn some bridges just
because he doesn't want to allow a draw
I don't think so where do you stand on
that question Danny
again to clarify for the viewers if you
get a single draw the adoption papers
are denied it has to be 10 wins in a row
so
um
I think I think that Magnus will play
ruthless chess as long as he can do it
with a reasonable amount of risk and I
think from that perspective
Magnus likes his chances in mutual time
pressure we've said before that the
Knight is often trickier than the bishop
and and therefore your opponent can
often blunder into a fork and
so I'm kind of dodging the question I
don't know that Magnus is thinking about
the adoption but I don't think he's not
thinking about it and you he's thinking
about it uh with those 20 seconds that
he spent and he's going for it he's
going for the win here and it's the best
feeling in the world you're up double
double
so I mean yeah you lose the game worse
comes to worse it's not an issue and
that's what makes Magnus so scary now
he's going to take even more risk uh
than he usually would and I think he's
getting rewarded for it suddenly he's
got the initiative and a bunch of forks
are being threatened Piggies on the
seventh anybody
yeah I was going to say objectively I
don't really know that I disagree with
it regardless of the motives I mean you
have an opportunity to keep pushing and
here comes some tricks and here comes
the night back to F5 it goes back to F5
it goes
check
yeah you tuck the King on H6 you're
threatening Rook D4 and Rook takes F2
all kinds of stuff oh 57 though no no
but I think if white can oh he just
floated the bishop but it's still a game
Danny it's still a game okay eight oh
man but he's losing the thread here
rookie eight and keep chasing the Knight
I think he can force repetition kick it
off six and he's gotta make sure it's
all mating him on h8 C5 no oh he put her
mate Rook F7 okay seven and Rook F5 was
made but he wins the game anyway
oh my God Magnus missed mate in one
anyway
there's another one
what do I have to do to even draw this
guy
yeah that was such a nice idea the go
for the mating net with the King Under
Fire there in the corner but it
backfires
oh man well Wesley hasn't survived a
single time scramble this entire match
against Magnus Magnus is just too
accurate when both sides have two
seconds on their clock the guy is yeah
made in one who cares he found a way to
win the rook and sometimes Chad makes
too big of a deal of missed mates Danny
when you see a way to win a rook you're
often not even looking uh for checkmate
yeah Amber he's got two seconds on his
clock I know it's hard to admit it but
Magnus is sometimes still a human
well again unless you saw the mate
before you went into the lion Diner
you're right and it is actually the
correct approach from a human's
perspective because as we always say
humans don't care about the best way to
win they care that they win and
computers make things look silly in
terms of the math and oh you miss me and
won this and that but obviously Magnus
doesn't care because scoreboard as the
kids would say right a Dub's a dub and
uh or as Vin Diesel would say for all of
those coloring book fans out there
winning's winning minimum mile then
uh you know into a mile
uh
I do know who Vin Diesel is but I've
never seen a movie with him
you
okay have you seen Guardians of the
Galaxy you know he's the voice of group
nope I have not seen is that a superhero
movie
yes I don't watch superhero movies
what about Fast and Furious which is
basically a superhero movie nope I'm
okay I like action movies but I feel
like that's too much action and not
enough you know slow plot development
for my taste
that's that's probably the
understatement of the century when it
comes to Fast and Furious yeah exactly
so I I agree with you no no
disagreements there
yeah
um there's a lot of mixed results on how
people feel about Fast and the Furious
I'm I'm gonna I'm just leave it at that
hey Different Strokes for different
folks chat
that's right that's right
although speaking of tyler1 who was
mentioned earlier and recently reached
the 1000 rating Plateau shout out to you
Tyler we know you're watching Chef shows
these days secretly alone on your phone
making sure that no one hears you don't
tell your brother e-rob I think Vin
Diesel could play tyler1 in a movie what
do you think Chad let's have some fun
here who plays tyler1 in the movie about
him becoming the greatest chess player
of all time right I think it's such an
improbable plot that you need an actor
like Vin Diesel to pull it off so I
nominate Vin Diesel to play tyler1 if
anyone in can everyone in chat can give
me a better suggestion than Vin Diesel
to play tyler1 you get a one year
Diamond membership you have to convince
the judge of one that's me
you're the Judge Jerry and executioner
Danny I am I am on this one so
okay opposite color to Bishop end game
another better position for Magnus
Carlson
will this be number eight
what what Danny DeVito was a great
question Jason straight straight okay
this is good the rock is is certainly up
there but no I think that the the rock
is Too Tall Vin Diesel is shorter than
he appears and I think tyler1 is also
pulling some Shenanigans if I get a
Feeling
Margot Robbie to play tyler1 okay anyway
you guys are off the rails back to the
chest
back to the chest and back to a
suffering end game for Wesley down on
the board down on the clock how many
times have we said that in the three
minute portion well seven for every one
of magnus's wins
yep and if he gets his eighth victory
he's already got seven right now
and Wesley with good drawing chances
here King E6 was an excellent move
getting out of the lateral pin and
activating his King trying to force
white Circ away from B7 and forcing the
Knight first and foremost away from C4 I
think this is moving the trend of the
game is in Wesley's favor here he should
not lose this with accurate defense
I like it I like it he only has a minute
and 13 seconds though
uh Rook G8 what is Magnus doing he's
doing oh he's got G5 coming and the
bishop is running out of square whoa
whoa but he's blundered Rook before he
missed it he might lose it he missed it
extra pawns and he's just realized it
it's a great idea by Magnus but Wesley
has to be very careful where he puts his
King because if you put it on C6
amazingly if we could pull up an
analysis board Danny I think this is
Worth showing yeah let's do it if
instead he didn't find the right square
but let's show how you could have gone
wrong with King to C6 so Knight takes
you through Rook B3 and you're like well
how could white possibly save the night
well the point is Rook CA check if you
go to D7 you'll give up C5 and white
defends the Knight so you have to go to
D6 if you go to B6 you give up the rook
and here you allow The Rook to navigate
over to D3 and white maintains his loot
so Wesley remaining on top remaining
alert here if you go here there's a
there's a check and a win of The Rook
this way so
all right Magnus is going to fail at his
time
up he's gonna fail his adoption task I
said it
I'm jinxing them commentators curse
The Only Way Wesley actually loses this
is basically he misses some sort of
mating mating net but does Seattle wait
to play for a win here
oh take C7 takes H7
yeah oh no
wait why give up response like that
unless they should have taken the draw
there
with just checking the king with the
Rook but now we're in an all-out
scramble again where Magnus has winning
chances once more he does although if
Wesley plays his cards right and pushes
that seep on at the right moment he
should have enough uh to counterbalance
White's Pawn majority
I mean Rook Hade or something seems
right to make sure that you can stop the
pawn from behind because doing it from
C7 is way too flimsy yeah there's too
many checks too many ways you lose your
knight so don't put your Rook on that on
pre-square
oh he does play Rook h8
but uh
Wesley thinking about it but there's
nothing black can do a year ago he
avoids adoption the option is over
Wesley so is a little bit of a smile
Hikaru Nakamura is Happy Magnus doesn't
get one adoption closer to to his to his
all-time record as I said earlier there
shall be no new members of the Magnus
Carlson Family
let it be known throughout the land he's
got a lot of mouths to feed as it is
also there's no world where Danny DeVito
was a better suggestion than Vin Diesel
okay like I appreciate the chat poll
here and I love our community team for
trolling me but I'm not giving a diamond
it was hilarious but I'm not giving a
diamond membership for that I think I
named the best the best actual actor and
I think it's okay for me to be judge
jury and execution on this one
respectfully
um
so as judge jury and executioner of the
decision of whether I deserve to be
judged during an executioner over this
said topic I rule in favor of me okay
that's a kangaroo court if I've ever
seen one there you go all right anyway
uh Tyler won the movie about becoming
the greatest chess player of all time
starring Vin Diesel
I think they chose Danny DeVito just
because his first name is Danny
no like I mean Tyler one is is kind of
shorter and and he is bald by choice I
don't know the Danny DeVito was that's
neither here nor there
um
and I love Danny DeVito don't get me
wrong
um
all right
the three-minute portion could very well
come to a close with this game
I am very much excited about the idea at
this point it remains an idea
of Wesley so getting a win
that's where I'm at
I'm excited about that and I love
rookie1
I like the e-file okay stay with me I
like the fact that this night's a little
lost and tender right
uh okay
come on Wesley let's get an advantage
here I like the E4 Square mm-hmm
if you've got the advantage he's got the
and so does Wesley so
he has an advantage he had this
structure against Sally Reza a bunch of
times and Wesley struggled in this
structure with white black has this
annoying idea of moving the bishop back
and then deploying the Knight via H6 to
F5 so yeah White's got the positional
dominance in the center but black has
the long-term possibility of kingside
play I do like that Wesley is up a
minute on the clock because he has
struggled big time on many many fronts
in this three minute portion but uh as
well as the clock
indeed
Bishop to G6 is played to use the F5
square but the Knight pops into E4
we're trading Knight improvements
potentially right now indeed we are
Magnus says I raise you one both of our
Knights are better where they stand this
9986 is kind of a donkey mm-hmm
I'm just saying that I didn't say that
to do that okay come on damn girl
hmm
I love it okay you want some more yeah I
think some more would be amazing
I don't know whatever I'm going with
this yeah baby Carlson
all right Bishop H5 is played
and uh
very good move
what we have here is a very nice
a page five I don't like this move
previously because now I drive and very
strong players spawns on King's side yes
yeah
H5 yeah
Etc
then Feingold rolls over in his grave
but we do like the bishop coming back to
F2
he doesn't
yes and that's why Magnus played B6 we
saw alireza making the same type of move
trading a pair of knights and now it's
black using the queen side of his
Advantage I think one of the instructive
things about the way Magnus plays is he
he redefines the concept of pressure
like you think okay in this position I
have to attack on the king's side is
black and white attacks on the queen
side for Magnus he uses the entire board
as this cannabis even if white is the
one with the ostensible advantage on one
side of the board he says no I'm going
to be the one to strike on both sides I
own the board
Knight T4 striking at the center
yep I love it well said
he creates counter play over here where
there may be opportunities for blunders
or attacks you have to watch out for the
a pawn
it's it's also scary because if Wesley
can Parry the threats and pick up a
couple of pesky himself then you know
some pawns or pawns right apeshka is
apeshka is a peshka
which is about to land upwards Grail on
D3 that's fair that's fair
is also one step from becoming a real
boy just asking Pinocchio
that's fun
there you go
all right
what happens
say two is it Rook takes A2 you're
threatening things
okay he goes for takes a two you're
threatening this maybe white has to get
the Queens off the board he does oh nice
move by Magnus and you can't take Danny
because The Bishop's gonna land on D4
and then the Rook on F1 and uh let's not
talk about that position okay first rule
about Bruno we don't talk about Bruno
and in this case a back rink mate is the
same as a Bruno
and if you don't get that reference
you've never seen Encanto and I am no
longer happy
man
I
have not seen whatever he just said I
didn't even hear what you said
yeah but you gotta see Disney movies and
at times are phenomenal okay there's and
and I'm not just saying that so I don't
get sued you know because that's what
Disney does but I'm just saying like
there's some great films and kanta was a
great I know very you know that's all
I liked my share of Disney movies I
loved Aladdin as a kid I loved Mulan so
you know I was at least five percent of
me was a normal kid I mean the other 95
was the sitting in the basement reading
veretsky uh but you know let's let's not
talk about those 95 Magnus by the way
he's down to five seconds it's like it
doesn't matter Danny when Magnus says
five seconds you feel like he has five
hours
still playing the best moves on the
board plays the move rookie for the E6
Pawn will fall by the way it is
well we are down up against the wire
either this game ends in seconds or it
is our last game in the three minute
portion we see that clock now down to 15
seconds above Magnus Carlson
um and
I don't think Wesley is looking to
resign and get another three minute game
in if this was a closer match Wesley
would probably resign this position
Donya and try to get another three
minute game
but it's not a close match it's not a
close match and you might as well bleed
and drink this cup down to its drags
looks like Wesley is likely to save the
game if he can get that D2 Pawn but he
doesn't want to take it and allow a pawn
end game because black is the one of the
outside passer I feel like practically
Magnus still has good winning chances
here he's going to push before establish
the bishop and Wesley has to quickly
calculate whether or not he can get away
with Knight takes D2 it looks like he
can but it's a really scary move to play
good job he does it
he laughs in the face of danger the king
upon oh that was a table baseball
confirming a draw it was in a blunder it
was just a gray bar Danny
heart attack
I'm sorry I don't know why I burst into
song but sometimes it helps me get along
with the trauma that I'm facing my
therapist says it's okay so you're not
wrong into song there you go you're not
wrong to burst into song
and I draw Wesley a little relief of
course but nonetheless holding that
final final game at this point you got
to take what you can get Danny
indeed you do he uh he doesn't lose the
last game as we head into bullet and and
that's gotta be
It's gotta feel a little bit good right
he is still down 11 games in the match
which is the same score we left at the
half halfway point of the three minute
portion so
Real Talk we've never seen in 11 game
deficit overcome it would take returning
to favor and winning 11 straight games
against Magnus Carlson
um as as Wesley so once lost to Magnus
on a casual Wednesday on chess.com but
uh all right
it's a casual Tuesday not a casual
Wednesday but every day is a day for you
to feel your best Donnie you got to take
care of your body you got to put healthy
things into your body if you want to
have healthy things come out you are
what you eat you are what you drink I
see you rolling your eyes off camera at
me no no it doesn't mean I'm not I I
feel it no I know you're not I'm teasing
I think it adds to the fun drama because
I want fans to pay attention when I tell
them that ag1 is their next smart move
they are artificial I don't even know
what it is they're an official partner
and if you go to drink ag1.com
chess or just use the command age you
want to get a direct link you can use
our chess login page
to get whatever that is that you're
getting age you want I do drink it
regularly it is awesome it is tasty I do
love it and uh and that's it we thank
them for sponsoring the SEC
onya I thank you for being who you are I
just want you know that like there's no
conditions just who you are I thank you
for that
all right thank you for being who you
are this has been such a fun match not
for Wesley but for all of the rest of us
and we've had courtside seats to
magnus's magisterial display in the
first two segments you don't want to
miss the bullet Danny just from the
perspective of Magnus playing his very
best chess which is by definition on
miscible action regardless of the score
you heard the man he said it sometimes
you stick around to see if LeBron's
gonna drop 60. right we're gonna find
out or will Wesley give us some fun the
other way either way we've got the
bullet portion ahead don't go anywhere
it's the 2023 speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase and it is back in
just a few
thank you
love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variants Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more
see you in the arena on chess.com
and change your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze there start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which recharge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
and bang your powers of Chess and
sorcery to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this music is so hot right now Magnus
Carlson's hair looking like he did it up
that way
shout out to chat and everyone is having
a great time today shout out to Magnus
Carlson for putting on a show but it's
not over yet he's got the bullet ahead
Donya and uh we know he wants to get it
done because as we look at the bracket
getting back to the final is the first
goal avenging his loss last year is the
second and uh he has his eye on the
prize he does indeed Hikaru and Magnus
have put through the most impressive
performances of the SEC thus far
although mvl not to be outdone we've had
so many blowouts Danny in this year's
SCC not because a certain category of
players are not trying or they're tilted
it's just because the people currently
in the semi-finals are unbelievable and
we are kicking off our final half an
hour of action
the all four players in the semifinals
as you said are unbelievable and uh we
said this at the top of the show for
those who may have missed it fun fact
only four players have ever reached a
final of an SCC and those four are the
four men left standing
Nakamura Maxine Bashe the grav Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so does it look like
Wesley so is going to get back to a
final this year as we kick off the
bullet portion but uh
you know historically those four guys
have been the best four players in SCC
history obviously and uh mvl the only
other player to beat Magnus Carlson in
this format besides Hikaru Nakamura I
can't wait for that match tomorrow by
the way Naka Naka versus mvl is going to
be a blasty MC blasterson
unmissable action tomorrow but there's
the scary concept of you know like
Michael Jordan playing to the best of
his ability and no matter how many shots
he hit you're just not going to be good
enough because the guy is the best in
the universe and you're I'm getting
those vibes right now for Magnus Carlson
if he continues to play on this level
there might not be I mean God himself
won't be able to stop him Wesley trying
to stop Magnus from running him over on
the king side here but Knight takes F7
transitions the game into a position
with a devastating initiative another
great move Rook is coming to D1 Danny
Bishop to D6 and this is unplayable in a
bullet game
and if you block the check B7 hangs with
check so instead we're going to choose
the poison of Rook D1 Bishop D6 and
Magnus Carlson this is just this is for
dunk radonka bunker I'm pretty sure
that's a scientific phrase you can look
up and you see Magnus Carlson's face
verdonker Bonker that's what's going on
right now uh 56 population Magnus
Carlson no that didn't make any sense
that didn't make any sense but you're
you're you're pushing you're trying to
keep Pace with the awkward cringe that I
bring and I appreciate that
um
ugh that
that did not go well
no
and Magnus picks up right where he left
off
yep
and Magnus by the way note that like
this is a 12 game lead but Magnus isn't
you know there's no bong Cloud here
there's no time for Reno Valley who
right no unnecessary Shenanigans he's
still playing mainstream openings and
intends to crush the joy out of his
opponent currently he's not gonna let
this slip no and it's not because he has
a vengeful streak or he takes pleasure
and rubbing it in Magnus is not like
that as as a person but as I was saying
earlier uh when he had you know that
three or four point lead Magnus is a
scientist right he strives for
Perfection and he doesn't care about the
situation in the match he could be up 68
points and he would be playing the same
way that's one of the many many things
that make him uh the terrifying opponent
that he is
yep and he has a long history of doing
it often referred to it usually when
we're covering you know classical chess
that everyone remembers as he was moving
up the ranks when he had already
clinched the sink-filled cup and then he
played for the win against levana Ronin
in that last round and we remember just
being like wow like this is like just
ruthless so many people down here would
have just taken the draw right yeah and
again that's the type of attitude that
he applies to classical chess he applies
it here to speed chess
and
it's just uh it's brutal at times if you
are on the receiving end of it and so
you feel for Wesley so you know he's a
great player one of the very few who can
go toe-to-toe with Magnus Carlsen but
today is not that day
well Magnus Carlson's form today was
reminiscent of his form against nepo
with one difference he eliminated
virtually all blunders Magnus Harrison
has not committed in my memory a single
one move blunder or one move tactical
mistake in this entire match and that's
why he beat nepo by something like 11
points those are the additional points
he's making up against Wesley when
Magnus Carlson doesn't even give you
that
I mean I I realistically think only
Hikaru has a chance against him
yeah
agreed town again we've been living in
agreements we have this this event you
know population is getting bigger
there's a lot of people in agreement
Townsville post office and a convenience
store now you know it's like a Boom Town
we're we're setting we're setting things
up for Success here you know there's
rumor about you know a Chipotle coming
in you know maybe even a Costco if we're
lucky agreement town is booming for me
and Dania life is good
would be amazing
Costco you like Costco
uh I don't but there's someone in my
immediate family who does
who loves Costco I would let you fill in
the blank as to who it might be I loved
I caught I am a Costco I mean Costco is
is an enjoyable experience you know
listen it's funny because I feel the
opposite of Ikea Ikea I'm convinced
is the doorway to the underworld like I
believe if you take one wrong turn on
some aisle in Ikea you're not setting up
Furniture like you are in purgatory one
step away
from the Devil Himself so be careful
when you go to IKEA I'm not a fan
um Danny I'm getting some bad vibes for
me I don't like uh I think you have a
bad Ikea in mind but I like driving to
that other store but because of all the
traffic in the parking lot it really
comes at a big Costco
commentator that Hess warns me about
when he's like Donya is for good reason
who can take you to the next level with
awkward it's just like
for a good reason okay table based eval
Bar says draw
um God I am partial to the lingonberry
Jam at Ikea that's really the only
reason I would ever go there there's
that Lincoln Berry Jam that I highly
recommend to anybody who likes sweet and
savory mixes
mocha I actually have never tried it so
I feel like I maybe I need to have this
experience to change it but I'm not a
big fan of Swedish meatballs shout out
to production working super hard behind
the team behind the scenes oh no no
[Applause]
of stopping the Pawn King no three any
just Flags
I don't even need to use it but I will
when it comes to stopping past pawns
Donya Knights are donkeys
no peace I have nothing to say ass
when it comes to stopping past pawns you
know
especially Corner Ponce Danny the a pawn
is the knights Kryptonite yep it is the
biggest Achilles seal of the night and
Wesley is I don't even want to say until
I'm not getting those kinds of Vibes
he's just demoralized for lack of a
better word he just he's just thoroughly
worn out by you know the labors of
facing Magnus Carlson when you're
getting blown out and the match seems to
drag on forever
again agreement Town population us but
don't go anywhere everybody we're going
to have some more fun bowl of moments as
you know and then an interview with
Magnus Carlson by the way you said we
hadn't seen a blunder that was the first
one on the board Magnus plays Queen B3
and blunders a piece and and there he
goes this reaction it's not exaggerated
he's genuinely frustrated
he's up a million and a half games but
he's pissed after that move and it it is
literally the first
double question mark we the first
blunder we've seen Magnus make in the
entire day that's crazy I mean and the
game is not over by the way he manages
to Garner two pawns for the piece that
was inaccurate right there by Wesley who
could have played Knight takes E3 now
Queen takes C5 runs into B3 and Magnus
needs to try to keep his Queen side
intact maybe even play B4 and quickly
try to push A4 and P5 he's not going
down going gentle uh into that good
night he might be down up 13. uh he
might be going to the good night uh Pub
if he loses this game but he's gonna try
to prevent that from happening
yep you might go to the good night poem
if he wins this game right exactly
either way quietly you don't need an
excuse to go to the good night exactly
there's uh Magnus is going to make this
tricky and especially with time pressure
being Mutual
which is where we're headed here I mean
okay Wesley also has an edge there which
is important
but okay Magnus not happy does not want
to lose this game hoping for a Swindle
but Wesley doing a very good job of
converting and I want the victory I want
the doubly the doubly So Right Wesley
for a reason give me the dub oh okay I
just gotta I just got that I forgot what
his first name was very good very good
one Demi I'm here to help you out I'm
gonna keep driving home bad humor until
either chat like really freaks out or
you acknowledge it so I got your back
bruh we're good yeah I have Provo this
was a very good pun
all right doubly so let's go get a win
[Music]
um this one's over he should convert
he's up a piece
he's up a full piece and he's gonna win
the C5 fund that might trigger
resignation
yeah C5 Falls the Rooks are traded
simplification killed the Magnus
right and get some pieces off the board
and this one wins itself do not repeat
for a draw
okay
but he's he keeps procrastinating on the
task of winning that C5 Pawn I thought
King E6 there
oh oh my gosh I thought this was a
repetition I thought that was three
times it's only because White's King is
on H3 rather than G3 oh my God that's I
was gonna say the exact things you said
it faster than I could it was the exact
same position besides the white king not
on the same square and it was the exact
same position three times but that one
check by Wesley saved it heads up
Magnus is like that big boss who keeps
fighting even though his head has been
chopped they think doesn't matter he
will keep fighting and fighting fighting
and King G6 there would have given up a
piece oh he bluttered made it two F4 oh
my God what
which one he missed
he missed anyway he's gonna win the
bishop back he had maintenance two
but he's still alive
oh my God how on Earth did he do this
I'm still just as impressed dude because
he's gonna make the draw
talk about a Hydra of a monster as you
said you cut off his head he just
Sprouts a new one that is the final boss
known as Magnus Carlson
um
the reason they invented the double tap
rule in Zombieland was for zombies that
come back to life and so there you go
it's a draw Magnus Carlson did not
deserve to draw that game but therefore
he did because he did so you know
got nothing to do with it
you got that one deserves got nothing to
do with it
deserves got nothing to do with it that
rolls right off the tongue might enter
my regular rotation it's one of the most
famous lines
wow wait it is all right we still got
work to do team we still got work to do
with Donya hey everyone calm down it's
okay
anyway back please tell me the Swedish
meatballs what at least tell me that
what what song is that from
no it's not a song it's a movie the
actor who said it first one to say the
actor who said deserves got nothing to
do with it gets a one month Diamond
membership I'm watching chat
I gotta give away some diamonds
but I cut you off what was it about Ikea
the Swedish meatballs I'm not a big fan
but production shout out to the team
working super hard behind the scenes
brought it up here in our in our
broadcast channel on Slack
and production is doing a phenomenal job
can we get a shout out to them real
quick Chad look at look at the shows
look at the graphics look what we're
bringing to you are you not appreciating
the content on chess.com
because that team is crushing it shout
out to the broadcast team we love you
it's easy to take everything for granted
when it's working well which it is 99 of
the time but there's actually people who
are making all of the stuff on your
screen happen and making our jobs uh
easy and fun
shout out to production this bud's for
you if this show was sponsored by a
company that has bud in their name but
it's not so this bud's not for you
however we appreciate you production and
broadcast we love you
um okay Wesley loves the idea of
bringing a knight to E2 huh look at
could Wesley get
a victory could he get anything going
here I don't think so because Queen H3
check and then Bishop G4 Bishop F3 was a
problem on the king side so Wesley
escapes with his King and he'll have to
find the right time to play 92 maybe go
King E1 first and get the king as far
away from the wrath of Black's queen as
possible
okay someone said Unforgiven and Clint
Eastwood mods if you don't mind let's
find that person and give them a diamond
membership hit them up with their
username I see multiple people saying it
correctly now but I don't know who was
the first one to give us our Clint
Eastwood reference
Magnus is winning another game
well there you see the Magnus
measurement stick tool the game was even
and then it goes in his favor and look
at that line Dania is that when it comes
to Justice and in the universe and the
bitterness of life sometimes whether you
deserve it or not has got nothing to do
with it that's the point of the line
I see deserves to have nothing to do
with it consider myself educated
yeah
it's an it's an Infamous epic epic
moment anyway bikini once brilliant by
Wesley so let's go I don't even know why
but hey yo sacrifice is The Rook I guess
although that's a bit of a of a red
herring brilliant there because I think
the Rook was trapped Pro tip
um
Primo that's a dangerous Primo but look
at Carlson even though the King on C2
was relatively safe now it's not safe
anymore you have to take back with the
King and then Black's Queen is going to
deliver a check on e4 we're likely to
get a Perpetual check he's no wonder
before made before me if you take on C3
and you drop the Rook on A1 and you lose
another game
King takes C3 was B4 Checkmate you
almost wish it happened because we love
seeing mate on the board instead Magnus
picks up the Rook on A1 and the fun
continues for Mr Carlson
um we have 15 minutes so we are halfway
through the bullet portion
and uh yeah
and yeah Danny you know who had four
points at the end of a particular match
against Magnus Carlson it was Fabi and
the way that this match was going we
might get something like 22-4 I mean
Wesley's shaking his head he's
frustrated he wants this match to end
but that's part of what makes the SEC
the SEC you get the close matches in the
armageddon's and then you get the
monsters and when the monsters are in
good form this is what they do to their
poor opposition
yep
and magnus's opponent is a monster
himself in many respects so it's just
crazy exactly one man's gold another
man's treasure or one man's monster
another man's friend I don't know I'm
inventing a line that actually sounds
deep it's one Dance Monster another
man's friend it's like a kingdom of
stuff right there in the Kingdom of the
blind the one-eyed man is King it's like
those types of quotes that I really like
yeah yep
um
shh
yeah and I'm gonna say Danny this is not
much to say although we will throw out
the the fun factoid stat that we've
officially reached the largest lead of
any match this year at this point 18 to
4 is the biggest margin
um
yeah
this looks like a draw although Magnus
has won so many equal and outright worst
end games that I hesitate uh to forecast
any potential evaluation but yeah this
Pawn end game is all locked up we're
gonna get a bunch of King shuffles here
unless Wesley plays the move G5 the way
to lose this for black is to trade the G
Pawn for white F1 and give white an
outside passer on the king's side so if
you're Wesley just stay put
agreed again agreed Town Town exactly I
agreed he forgot the second part of that
over that City
there you go
we gotta find the winner of this Clint
Eastwood things I got to give away a
diamond membership today
yeah there was a lot of there were a lot
of guesses so
might be a photo finish
I'm gonna guess our audience was young
enough and or they didn't know it off
the top of their head that they probably
just Googled deserves got nothing to do
with it and the moment you do
you get your answer I'm not taking away
anyone from their movie trivia you know
but not everyone's pop culture game is
on point all the time as we've learned
with my co-host I feel like Magnus might
play F5 or something I mean you actually
can play F5 and it's still a draw in a
in a 30 second game Danny That's a
classic flagging technique what you do
is you pre-move 10 or 15 moves and then
at the moment your opponent least
expects it you play a move like F5 so
you set your opponent up for a pre-move
and then you shove that pawn through
what that is is unnecessary in the
context of this match it's it's
unnecessary roughness right and you
would be exactly indecent indecent
handling of your lead on the match on
the match scoreboard is what the flag
would be I'd pull the flag out Magnus
you're getting the penalty unnecessary
unnecessary usage
um of the dirty flagging technique
although Bortnick would love that
bortnick's a pro at that but it's risky
right because if you play those moves
with any moment where your opponent
doesn't pre-move then it's over you lose
so
um yeah
it's fun stuff yeah yeah Ali Reza kind
of also pioneered a lot of those
pre-moved tricks back in the in the
early days of 30 second chess back when
I used to play these nighttime matches
with them I learned a lot of dirty
flagging techniques from
from Reza but right now Magnus is oh no
oh Knight C4 resigns and you drop the
minor piece
yeah it's just going off the rails yeah
Magnus was hardly happy about that
himself or at least he appeared to be
slightly dejected and there you go the
lead is 19 and a half to four and a half
has let me ask you this Danny has Wesley
won
one no two games this whole batch
how many games has Wesley won
the fact that we can't even remember I
think speaks volumes about the course of
this match
yeah
all right we have our winners dubic on
Twitch and
Factory factor is here on YouTube you
each get a one month Diamond membership
reach out to Ahmad give them your
username
um yeah he hasn't won in a while and
again we know that and it's hard because
you keep talking about it feels like
we're adding insult to injury but Wesley
knows this isn't his best day at this
point he's being a professional which is
finishing the match clock
oh
Queen F4 or queen B4 you can't touch the
roof for yeah and you can't touch the
Rook
because of the windmill you take the
bishop on C8 can we well not it's it's
in the in a blitzwide show the game the
line with Knight takes C8 but it's a
moot point right now uh Magnus is going
to support his Knight with Rook D1 and
Bishop F4 and he's winning again
yeah or that would have been better
back to a great time maybe I would go B5
and B4 and try to separate the queen
from the night I think that's Wesley's
only chance but look at the clock
situation he's down 30 seconds and you
know
that's not gonna see it
that's that's another loss that's a KO
now Knight takes C8 is a threat which
forces the exchange and with it the
resignation
another game in the books for Magnus
Carlson we have nine minutes and some
odd seconds remaining
yeah this is this is going to be very
very similar to the Magnus Fab imagine
this is I remember feeling these
feelings uh in the last
and the home stretch of that match where
from Wesley's perspective it just
doesn't end you just have game after
game and loss after loss and eventually
you almost become numb to it because
you've already accepted that yes I'm
gonna get completely blown out this
match but it doesn't really make it any
easier it's still just as painful it's
still just a saddening it's not the fact
that you lost a Magnus which is
understandable it's it's a way that
you've lost and all the blows that you
had to suffer throughout the match we
feel for Wesley this is really really
tough
yep
yeah apparently we're updating who
actually got it so don't don't stress I
know everyone wants those Diamond
memberships if it was a photo finish
we'll give away two on Twitch so
everyone relax our mods are gonna find
it I'm sorry back to this it's also 1am
for both players by the way local Berlin
and Oslo time so our players are up late
to make this thing happen
we appreciate that
well Magnus usually plays that second
title Tuesday so for him I think 1am is
is early days you know it's just when
the when the date of which when does the
next title Tuesday start are we there
well it's seven Eastern not only are we
there we've already finished it we we we
just finished it and so yes there is
there is another title Tuesday that also
happened today all right two of them
well
um
this looks like maybe some outside nope
no real chances to get
anything
I mean maybe I would I would prefer
white here because the a pawn black
sapon is on a dark Square so it's more
targetable by White's Bishop as you're
indicating the problem is Bishop A3 and
Bishop B4 an excellent defensive
maneuver for Carlson Bishop C5 here with
blunder to Rook C8 so you could
definitely find a way to lose this if
you're Wesley I think he's gonna go
Bishop C5 now but Magnus could support
his Bishop with a rook to B1 or even
Rook to A1
yeah Rook A1 is a fun way to do it
although it doesn't work
on C8
okay we're just playing playing lines in
our head here everyone but that was a
fun little way to lose instead we get a
bunch of passers a bunch of Queens
it's just good old-fashioned family fun
right here right and this is just you
know you lose a queen you get a new one
nbds I don't think Magnus could lose a
game if he tried
six and a half minutes left on the total
game clock
for rating us with 106 people we were
just talking about you
Morty good old pal
thank you Sasha hope your title Tuesday
stream went well and Magnus a little
reversal here with him playing B3 it
always feels kind of badass to imitate
the opening that your opponent has
played all match kind of showing that
yes I can also join in the party and
right now Magnus can play just about
anything and emerge Victorious
yep
I don't love this for Wesley G4 looks
pretty good here for white smashing
through Black's Pawn chain
[Music]
Knight C4 oh there's G4 look at the
tactic standing Knight D takes E4 is
coming in yeah it's a reverse French
right we see these variations in in
certain lines of the tarash with colors
reversed right
this or this idea not these variations
this idea and it's an aggressive one but
here comes the fun as I said good
old-fashioned family discovered checking
the kind that you write home to Mom and
Dad about and say I got a really cool
tactic and then they're like why are you
sending a letter you know it's the year
2023 you could just call us
this is Bobby fischer-esque for Magnus
Carlson there were only a couple of
players throughout chess history that
could dominate top opposition across all
formats of course
um because Blitz was less prominent in
Fisher's day Fisher did this in
classical chess and those U.S
championships where he scored 11 out of
11. hence the term Fisher prize which is
that additional 64 000 you get if you
win the US Championship with 11 out of
11. Hikaru Nakamura he's been doing this
online for many years but Magnus Carlson
this is what I was talking about Danny
three four years ago was he winning
online tournaments absolutely was he
amazing at Blitz absolutely was he
winning with these kinds of margins and
with this kind of speed and accuracy and
Blitz and in bullet no right this is how
Magnus Carlson has reshaped himself he's
entered the Hikaru Nakamura level of
domination as we see an excellent move
by Wesley slicing off the connection
between the queen and the Knight and
Black's Queen is going to pick up all
that stuff on that diagonal and Wesley
might win this win this game finally
okay
I agree with every point you made and
this is an improved Magnus Carlsen as if
that was a possible thing for us to say
he is uh we rebuilt him right he is the
the 64 000 man million dollar I don't
even know but he's he's playing
incredible chess although as we say that
and rightfully sing his Praises I think
mostly so knock on wood real effing
heart okay because I don't want to jinx
and I've done it before no bleeping
coming out of my mouth Wesley so gets
the dub
Bly so let's go Gotta feel good man at
last he takes the win and in very nice
style too rookie four was an amazing
four was a phenomenal move
that was
The Comeback begins
yeah total heads of play to see the
opportunity to cut off the queen from
protecting the Knight who has done you
said was critical because of the B3 Pawn
so all right two and a half minutes two
minutes plus remain there's a decent
chance if they play this one to the wire
that it's the last game depending on how
much increment gives us as far as extra
seconds on the clock
but it's been awesome
we've got uh we've got interviews ahead
and Magnus I don't know what this is is
causing consternation but it's
definitely not the match score
that's actually that's actually
We we forgot to pull back the stat again
for those who were here at the top of
the show one of the really interesting
story lines because it doesn't make any
sense is that Wesley so coming into this
event had never beaten Magnus Carlsen at
bullet on chess.com
his score is 22 losses zero wins and two
draws but not anymore Wesley so got his
first win against Magnuson bullet and
again it's kind of a crazy stat because
obviously Wesley is is way better than
losing this many games in rotor Magnus
but again when Magnus is on fire maybe
Wesley has some bad luck maybe he keeps
catching Magnus on a bad day here's
another brilliant move for Carlson
um things are falling apart on the king
side after F take C3 Queen takes E3 but
big moment Wesley so gets the dub note
that the queen can't come over because
the Rook hangs and if you move the king
there's a million things including Rook
to D2
Queen takes B5 Queen takes B5 he missed
it but he does something similar that
Rook is going to hit the Knight Danny
and Magnus is going to have the
advantage in the end game I think we're
probably gonna have another game after
this but it seems like yeah who holds
Wesley to six points I mean this is just
crazy
yeah it is crazy
okay
but okay
stylistically when things are going well
for Magnus and not going well for Wesley
I think sometimes the score gets even
further apart than is truly reflective
right of the player's strength we've
talked about that right sometimes you
know there's like when it rains it pours
against a certain player some players
their styles are are such that even if
you're getting outplayed they just
naturally get enough Dynamic games where
more victories happen but I think that
this is indicative of a really on four
Magnus Carlson a not not super on form
Wesley so but it seems worse than it
actually was because Wesley played a lot
of really good games but how many games
did he lose in a close manner Dania that
we had today right how many games did
you lose we're just in the final moments
Magnus was too good
and it started as early as the first
game right the very first game which
feels like it was in a different
universe and we are going to get one
final game with 15 seconds on the match
clock but it's purely academic at this
point obviously the very first game
Danny was an end game we thought that
Wesley was equal he had a comfortable
position boom he loses it he saves the
second game but then Magnus had maybe
three or four more victories in the five
minute portion that took on that exact
game Arc where they got into an end game
slightly better for Wesley or equal and
then in the snap of a finger Magnus
turns it around and wins I think that
honestly set the tone and then as they
transitioned into the three minute
portion Magna started winning more games
tactically and that's when the real tilt
began
for Wesley
indeed
indeed indeed indeed
indeed indeed town what's the population
up to now
well
honestly I think you know more people
have moved in and
um
we're considering putting in a small
airport we're not ready
you know
one of those airports you can get to
with one of those puddle jumpers where
you're oh no shaking the whole time and
nope doing that thing where you really
try to reflect on how much you
appreciate your loved ones because you
never know right and I've done it once
never again
yeah a little little puddle jumper and
uh
we're bringing people into agreement
Town population us on puddle jumpers now
I think it's an international airport
now flights to Canada and Mexico it's
like those international airports that
are called International Airport but
they barely have any Regional flights
and you're like oh in the 1960s there
was one flight to like Vancouver right
over the Border
yeah and we have since canceled that
flight exactly a long time ago Magnus
Magnus frustrated with where this
position is going by the way Wesley is
on Pace to have a good final game
right we shall see wow
now he rotates the Knight over to D6
gets the gets the Kebab on d70 ice
skater
and uh the final moves of this match
this blowout
Magnus Carlson continues his series of
incredible performances but all of this
is building up for
I was going to say the most epic final
of SEC history was last year I think
that the form of the players Danny tells
us that this year has the capacity to
beat last year in terms of entertainment
value and quality of play which is
saying a lot
I think it's quite possible plus it has
some some Stakes that I in some ways if
possible or even higher right the price
one's a little higher but that's not it
it's that these guys have now played in
the SCC and with Nakamura winning he
hadn't beaten Magnus in the two finals
where they had played previously and in
2020 he didn't play Magnus because MBL
beat Magnus and so
as good as Hikaru is there were always
questions of what happens when he runs
up against Magnus right that was the
truth and you see a confident Hikaru
Nakamura against Magnus Carlson that uh
that is is just it makes for some of the
most epic moments right in uh in chess
when they play and so now that he's
beaten Magnus in this format
I think beforehand people always thought
Magnus was the favorite in any format as
Magnus Carlson the favorite in the SEC
format anymore I don't know what do you
think maybe nobody goes up against
Hikaru no especially after a while the
BCC was one plus zero but nonetheless
every match Victory against Carlson adds
to your confidence and mvl of course
will try to play spoiler but that is
tomorrow right now today this Tuesday we
celebrate Magnus Carlson's incredible
Victory he advances to the speed Chess
Championship final Danny on the heels of
just an unbelievable vintage performance
and you called it it was an unbelievable
performance today by Magnus Carlson uh
he gets the job done in borderline
record-breaking fashion it was at one
point the the largest margin of Victory
we've had for any match so far this year
if you feel for Wesley so but Magnus
Carlson punches his ticket back into the
finals with a final score of 22-7 and he
wants to change that view for people who
think that Magnus is not the favorite in
this format
um he likes the challenge right and
almost to say now that he's here wasn't
happy then might be happy he even lost
last year it's a bit of an opportunity
to really bring the hype and the
eyeballs and have people tune in
to what will be an epic final again okay
we should not be looking past mvl men VL
beat Magnus in the 2020 speeches
Championship he plays Hikaru Nakamura
tomorrow do not look past the Frenchman
with three names Donya of course
realistically Hikaru is the very very
heavy favorite in that match but Hikaru
is not looking at that match like a
walkover because it's obviously not
especially given the form that mvl has
been in and VL has competed with Hikaru
Magnus in terms of speed and accuracy so
if we see good form from both players
tomorrow I think will very very likely
be actually a closer match than some
people might realize yeah well again I'm
saying that too because I was guilty of
in some ways thinking it was a foregone
conclusion for Magnus in 2020 when mvl
shocked at the time me and Robert Hess
commentating on it and no one should do
that tomorrow that said there is no
denying Hikaru Nakamura is the man to
beat right um and and he is the favor
for many reasons and so
um anyway good luck tomorrow who are you
commentating with
I actually don't remember Danny maybe
you can jog my memory I'm gonna be on a
plane um so it's not me so anyway have
fun but all right it's time for us to
also have fun you know what time it is
Donya
is it move of the daytime by any chance
it is well we like to call it our Savvy
move because it's presented by coinbase
and if you are a Savvy investor you
should probably diversify your portfolio
play a little bit in the crypto game if
not a lot depending on your flavor plate
and we've got coinbase bringing us the
Savvy move of the day John you this was
a game that went off the The Rails
quickly for Wesley but it was right here
I'll just set the tone with Wesley
finding the only way to keep it close
after this night before move he found
the nice Retreat and A3 and you're
thinking okay he saved the bishop but
tell us exactly what Magnus did here for
the Savvy move of the day and why it put
the game away well this next move really
epitomizes the moment in the match when
the wheels truly came off the bishop on
C4 is trapped but if you play B5 the
bishop escapes via the trade on D5 what
Magnus does is Knight takes E3 that is
our Savvy move of the day clearing the
D5 score so that the pawn can advance
the D5 re-trap the bishop and as a
result when the smoke clears of course
Wesley recovers the pawn by recapturing
on C4 but his position is now riddled
with holes and after C5 another Super
accurate move Magnus really accentuates
the weakness of White's pawns on D3 and
E3 as well as White's lack of
coordination there were Adventures Danny
later in the game but Magnus ultimately
bags the full point he jumped out to an
eight-point lead with this game and he
never looked back
he sure did well said sir this was the
official moment I agree with you what
you said earlier that this was this was
kind of really when the wheels were
officially off not to say that Magnus
wasn't playing well but we didn't
exactly know where was going to go but
this game was the first moment where
people were using that word in chat the
t word the Tilt word in online chess
right and there you go that's what
happened it was our Savvy move of the
day and uh want to give a big thank you
one more time to coinbase for that but
when we go to our break and then return
henceforth with we will be joined by a
winning Magnus Carlson who gets set for
a final uh or whether it's a rematch
versus sicaro or against MBL he's got to
be feeling pretty good about how he
played today so don't go anywhere we
catch up with Magnus just on the other
side of this break
oh
[Music]
foreign
love playing chess variants or just
looking for something new join us for
the variants Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions
learn a new variant and compete against
other players for prize money or just
play for fun look for Community Arenas
streamer Arenas and Championship events
six weekly Arena tournaments held every
Thursday will be followed by a
championship event with cash prizes
including a one thousand dollar first
place prize the third and final weekly
Arenas will be streamer Arenas featuring
gifted Subs as prizes when any of these
events to qualify for the championship
the variants Community series kicks off
on September 7th with King of the Hill
we're the first to occupy the center
wins the game but getting checkmated
still loses and join the variants club
today to learn more about upcoming
events how to participate and much much
more see you in the arena on chess.com
love playing chat
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our first semi-final in the 2023 speed
Chess Championship brought to you by
coinbase is in the books joining us now
is the winner of that match Magnus
Carlson who did so in
well Magnus how would you say your form
was today what would you say the fashion
was
yeah I I would say that uh I didn't feel
particularly energetic coming into the
match but I I did feel very calm and and
focused so I thought I played really
well
um at
at the start
um I think specifically the first three
wins that I that I heard were
of a very high quality and after after
that the match was
well not not over I think the match was
only really over after I
won that Kore con game
um where
I pushed the lead back up to four uh but
it definitely
set the the tone and I
I did feel at the start that
he wasn't playing particularly poorly uh
I was just playing playing well and I
think after that he started to uh to to
tilt a bit which
um invariably happens in such a
situation and I felt that I was always
really focused after uh and even though
like
the quality of my play was was varying a
bit
um I was always
trying as hard as I I could to
um to rack up the score as much as um
as much as possible so um
um it was uh was definitely a very good
session today
Magnus there was a stretch in the match
where you won seven games in a row to
start the three minute portion were you
aware of the number of games that you
had won and and how meaningful was it
for you uh to win game after a game what
kind of feelings does that produce
question here
yeah I I at some point I checked I
checked it and so that I had five wins
in a row
um and I think
probably the sixth was or sorry the
seventh was the one where
um
where I where I had the knights against
the bishop with good compensation and I
was where I was upon down and uh at that
point I was thinking
um yeah let's try and go for the uh for
the adoption otherwise I probably would
have acquiesced to a draw a bit a bit
earlier
well you got you got pretty close there
and I was it was definitely a show today
that you were putting on I want to
switch gears a little bit uh obviously
for many people talking about the uh the
potential next match up but before we
talk about what it might mean for you to
play hey Cara Nakamura in a rematch in
the final do me a favor and talk a
little bit about mvl and Hikaru and what
are your thoughts on that match nvl
style does it match up well with Hikaru
Maxime is is someone who's had good
scc's before obviously he's the only
other player to ever beat you and what
are your thoughts on mvl's chances
against Nakamura
Mike Sims chances lies and lies
inputting pressure with the
uh with the white pieces I think the
openings are going to be fairly uh
important that that is uh I mean there
were many reasons why uh she beat me in
that match in 2010 but one key reason
was that he was actually putting a lot
of pressure on me with um with the white
pieces so I think that will be key and
as you saw in his match against nihal he
actually had a 100 score with the with
the white pieces for for very long so I
think that is his yeah main main chance
but um yeah uh regardless I think
a car is a pretty pretty clear favorite
in in that matchup but um
um you never you never quite know I I'm
sure
um I'm sure there will be
I'm sure there will be a fight
yeah
um Magnus compared to the same time last
year when you were facing Hikaru in a
final given your dominance in online
chess over the last year do you feel
more confident about your overall Blitz
and bullet ability compared to uh last
year's finals
to be honest I was pretty sure that I
was going to beat him in the final last
time so
I don't think there is that much of a
that much of a difference there
well it's it's I mean I I know awkward
to ask if you're rooting for two of your
peers in top level chess but would you
rather have a rematch against hicaro if
you had your uh if you had your flavor
to pick
[Music]
um yeah well I'm still up to one against
him and in speed Chess Championship
matches so
you know whoever um whoever wins this
one is gonna have some some writing
rights for sure
so yeah I'm hoping for that Magnus we
have two chat chat
we have two chat questions before we
release you uh to your much deserved uh
rest the first one comes from walkie
Bogues who asks what is your favorite
time control in this format and in what
time control do you think you are
objectively the strongest
really depends on on my moods
um so today
I was as I said I was feeling pretty
um pretty calm and not super energetic
and I think for that
mindset the five one was uh
was definitely my best and I guess the
one that I enjoyed the most as well
whereas for instance against viritz I I
didn't have the patience to play
uh five one games at all so it really
depends on on the mood I think
where I have the biggest Edge against
um an average of the
of the field is in is in one one
uh but of course not against Hikaru
specifically where it's um where I think
it's fairly
fairly even but
um
for instance against Wesley I would say
that I have a like decent Edge in the
first two-time controls and then a
massive Edge and
and and the last one
well Magnus this is uh regardless of
which time control is of your your
objective best I think objectively you
played some of the best chess we've ever
seen in SCC history today uh that was uh
that was a pleasure to watch and
congratulations again and love the love
the uh the confidence heading to the
final whether it's whether it's Hikaru
and the rematch everyone wants or Maxine
and I wish you the best of luck there
man
congrats thank you so much and uh I am
happy with my play today so I will give
you that
good okay good
we like that
all right Johnny well there was Magnus
he should be happy with his play WoW was
that impressive he gets the job done
again by a final score of 22-7
your thoughts Mr nerojetsky on what we
just had there within an interview with
the goat and an interview that sets the
tone for how he's feeling heading to the
final being very confident
well all I'm going to say is that this
is going to be an epic final and the
fact that Magnus is in the final that's
not the surprising part and as crazy as
it is I am surprised by the way that
Magnus has blown his field out of the
water he's made people who themselves
are in a really good form look like
amateurs this has been one of the
greatest displays of online chess that
we've seen thus far can Magnus cap it
off by avenging last year's loss in the
final that remains to be seen speaking
of admissible action Danny these next
two matches between hikar and MBL and
especially the finals cancel whatever
you've planned for those time slots
you have to cancel cancel tomorrow first
and foremost Nakamura mvl is going to be
a thriller uh and then and then cancel
everything for the final cancel a couple
hours before and after two right maybe
watch a replay because this is the uh
the matchup everyone wants if it ends up
being Carlson Nakamura but even mvl
would have the Talk of the Town because
what an upset that would be so all right
today we didn't really get an upset we
got uh uh a very dominant performance by
Magnus Carlson let's take a final look
at the stats that uh that brought this
one home
Magnus Carlson takes 17 games decisively
that's that's pretty impressive seven
brilliances and two blunders only Donya
I leave it the floor to you sir it's
incredible Wesley got blown out and he
displayed 90 accuracy this is what I was
saying it's not like Wesley was losing
game after game due to blunder it's not
like he was tilting from the first
minutes of the match no not at all
a lot of the games were close and to win
as many games as he did required Mastery
in every area of the game openings
tactics he had some amazing attacks he
had some great defensive efforts and
overall I think the ultimate highlight
was magnus's end game play today across
the three segments some of the end games
that he put on display were worthy of
Great Performances In classical chess
you would never realize the time control
if you just looked at the moves
agreed uh it's crazy the accuracy level
in Blitz is PHA nominal that is that is
the scientific term I think let's remind
everybody of tomorrow's schedule janya
as a uh as a teaser as a taster once
again it will be Nakamura versus Maxine
Bossier the grav it'll be Dania
noraditsky and Casa Corley I'm told and
uh and what are your thoughts on that
gonna be an incredibly fun match good
start time not too early not too late
and Hikaru Nakamura the heavy favorite
but mvl has demonstrated Magnus
carlson-esque form thus far in the SCC
which I think is going to make this
match really really fun
[Music]
I can't wait for it I'll be a fan
watching you and and Casa then can't
wait of course for the final which I
also have to sit out this year travel is
something I hate but what I what I will
say right now is the team crushed it
thank you so much to everyone working
behind the scenes my partner that's you
you're just thank you Danny dude you're
so you're so great uh and uh thank you
to our players who brought their a game
and to everyone who enjoyed it in chat
enjoy tomorrow's show the second
semi-final and uh thank you so much for
being with us once again this is the
2023 speech has Championship presented
by coinbase thank you to all of our
sponsors and uh we will see you tomorrow
for the second semi-final until then
enjoy your night chat and we'll see you
on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign